the SCP Foundation has faced a number of
wide potentially apocalyptic threats in
its mission to uphold normaly and save
Humanity we know the SCP Foundation
could be ruthless in this Mission the
events of SCP 5000 before agent Petro
restarted the Universe show what happens
when the foundation is pushed to its
final decisions regarding normal C being
upheld in SCP 5000 it seemed that the
SCP Foundation decided to cease research
further into the anomaly they needed to
neutralize but what would have happened
if they didn't in any case we know the
SCP Foundation is dedicated to normaly
and the containment of the anomalous but
what happens when the SCP Foundation is
faced with a dire decision uphold
normaly or destroy their Universe the
Multiverse is a concept in science
fiction that has gained Mass amounts of
popularity over recent years especially
recently thanks to a certain wall
crawlers movie multiverses are parallel
universes that are similar or extremely
different from the main ones scientists
have pondered over the existence of a
Multiverse for hundreds of years but the
most popular being the many world's
interpretation a theory of quantum
mechanics that states there are many
worlds that exist in parallel at the
same space and time as our own some
interpretations even state that every
decision a person makes causes a branch
in reality where the person made the
other decision we're familiar with the
SCP foundation's run-ins with the
Multiverse from SCP
2935 death a cave that allows The
Wanderer to enter a parallel Dimension
that's fully and completely dead only
for the same thing to happen to their
own world once they return through the
cave or SCP
1437 a hole that allows the foundation
to send receive and read parallel
dimensional documentation from other
multiversal SCP foundations
combine those two concepts with an SCP
001 proposal the importance of an SCP
001 proposal is not lost on the
foundation researchers of the SCP
Foundation saved the SCP 00001 slot for
only the most dangerous apocalyptic or
widespread anomalies that could affect
the foundation itself humanity and
normaly arix SCP 001 proposal and the
research within its file found the
answer to the question we posed above
when the SCP Foundation is faced with a
dire decision do they uphold normaly or
destroy their universe and all the
people who live in it the file begins
somewhat different from what we're used
to with SCP Foundation files instead of
an item number or containment procedures
we begin with a yellow notice from the
records and information security
administration or Risa for short the
notice states that the following file
was received in 2026 from dimension
r42 is dimension r42 potentially the
cause of SCP 001 could they be attacking
this version of the SCP Foundation the
notice continues with the description of
the file that follows it it states the
file below describes an anomaly
threatening all members of humankind in
all of the Multiverse this file had been
emitted to this version of the SCP
Foundation for 8 minutes as an extremely
dangerous Cognito Hazard classified as a
class 5 Cognito Hazard capable of easily
destabilizing and penetrating this
universe however it was found to not be
dangerous only reading as a danger level
zero while this Foundation was unable to
quickly counteract this Cognito Hazard
it appeared to not pose a threat to the
affected universe's humankind part of
this notice is crossed out indicating
that it is no longer true there is a
high threat of repeated Cognito
hazardous or other forms of attack from
Dimension r42 instead said this part has
been replaced with the following fact
Dimension
r42 no longer exists did this version's
SCP Foundation fall to SCP 001 their
entire universe no longer exists so
perhaps this file that this Dimensions
SCP Foundation received could be a
potential warning under this race and
notice the reader is not greeted with
the standard foundation documentation
yet again instead it seems that the
original sender of this file left a note
for the readers of this file it says
greetings you are reading this dossier
in a parad dimension of the Rel
Dimension
r42 due to the Colossal size of your
world's address for your convenience
your dimension will be Hereafter
referred to as PD parad Dimensions it
seems as though we're reading this s SCP
001 file Through The Eyes of the SCP
Foundation in this so-called parad
dimension so if the original SCP
Foundation and their universe r42 is now
destroyed what does this mean for us the
not continues the following message has
been constructed by the SCP Foundation
of The Relic Dimension r42 and is
addressed to the SCP Foundation of parad
Dimension PD en closed you will find
information about SCP 001 which is a
threat to the Multiverse here we go SCP
001 is definitely the cause of R 42's
destruction but how can we be so sure of
this maybe as SCP 001 caused the
foundation to destroy their Universe the
note also includes the following
statement as you may have noticed this
message was preceded by a burst signal
containing a non-dangerous Cognito
Hazard the burst signal was constructed
in such a way that minimal change to the
signal would have caused indiscriminate
and overwhelming casualties among the
Denis of PD as you can see r42 is
capable of eliminating the absolute
majority of PD denisons but has not
exercised this capability in the context
above we ask you to consider this action
not as an act of aggression but as a
demonstration of the fact that r42 has
no pretension for conquest or other
forms of aggression towards PD take the
following information in Earnest well at
least this version of the SCP Foundation
is being somewhat friendly with the
parad dimension if R 42's SCP Foundation
needs to quell this multiversal threat
though why are they leaving it up to an
SCP Foundation that may not be so
inclined the SCP 001 file begins with
the object class this anomaly is of the
joint class of paradox aoon we know from
SCP 001 when day breaks or SCP 3999 that
aoon class anomalies are extremely
dangerous posing an immediate and almost
Unstoppable threat to normaly the SCP
Foundation all of humanity or even the
universe itself the Paradox part is
interesting what exactly is paradoxical
about a Napoleon class anomaly a
footnote explains this for us this
anomaly's distinguishing feature is that
in order to eliminate the anomaly that
will inevitably eliminate mankind it is
imperative to eliminate mankind or
release another K class event oh boy it
seems that the CP Foundation of r42 was
not eliminated by a CP 001 they
eliminated themselves to contain SCP 001
is this parad Dimension faced with this
decision now the containment procedures
of the SCP file continue on this note
the only way to contain SCP 001 and
prevent a ZK class cross reality failure
event is the annihilation of humankind K
class scenarios are not a concept used
lightly by the SCP Foundation we're
familiar with the Omega K class scenario
when we are completely rid of death or
XK Class end of the world scenarios so
we know the danger these anomalies hold
to humankind normaly and the world the
SCP Foundation will do anything to
prevent these scenarios from occurring
apparently even including the
elimination of all humankind or entire
universes the description goes more in
depth on the SCP 001 anomaly SCP 1
consists of all living members of the
homo sapien species living within
Dimension r42 and the parad dimension or
PD for short it seems as though this
anomaly was created out of a mistake
from Dimension r42 and PD as the
description States the anomaly first
came into existence and developed in The
Relic Dimension r42 and later activated
in PD by accident how could this have
happened are these Dimensions linked
much more closely than we first thought
let's continue with the description to
find more information scarily this
portion of the description contains a
note that states that unchecked growth
of SCP 001 will cause the annihilation
of the entire Multiverse the SCP
foundations of dimenstion r42 and PD are
not met with this decision as now the
entire Multiverse is at risk the r42 SCP
Foundation has done immense research on
the topic of the Multiverse of their
Universe after the big bang a finite
number of universes were created only 57
to be exact however only one dimension
was able to form Humanity Dimension r42
and it's unknown why this happened but
all we know is that with the destruction
of r42 and the potential annihilation of
PD Humanity will cease to exist in the
Multiverse the danger of
scp1 is that it has the anomalous
capability for widescale replication of
parent dimensions we are reading this
article from one of these parad
Dimensions so this SCP Foundation is
technically an anomaly that must contain
itself a parad dimension is defined as a
parallel reality that has an extremely
small deviation from its parent
dimension in this case PD is a parad
dimension of r42 it seems that these
parad Dimensions form as a result of
human decision making so if you've ever
been between a type of shirt to buy or
were confused on an examine guest to
question question a pair of Dimension
could have formed from this decision
where the pair Dimension has you take
the other choice because of this
Dimensions housing living instances of
SCP 001 uncontrollably grow a colossal
number of minimally differing pair
Dimensions every second no sign of pair
Dimensions have been found in the other
56 parent Dimensions the picture on this
file shows how PD has branched from r42
but at this point it seems that Millions
if not billions or trillions of parad
Dimensions now exist the real problem of
parad Dimensions is that the Multiverse
has a limit on the number of pair
Dimensions that can exist and once that
is crossed the ZK class cross reality
failure event will begin and the
Multiverse will be destroyed the r42
dimensions SCP Foundation has also
discovered that once humankind emerges
in the parad dimension they can begin to
have parad Dimensions themselves the ZK
class cross real failure event can be
expected to begin between 4 to 2 months
from the PD receiving this message to
summarize SCP 001 is humankind
specifically it's decisionmaking when a
person makes a decision a pair Dimension
may be created the Multiverse has a
limit on the number of pair Dimensions
it can have and since pair Dimensions
can have pair Dimensions they are
quickly approaching the ZK class cross
reality failure event the CP Foundation
of r42 is approximately 17 years ahead
of PD which allowed them to research and
develop containment procedures to
contain the anomaly and save the
Multiverse r42s SCP Foundation
discovered SCP 001 5 years before
writing the file we're reading now aside
from that they developed two operations
castling and minimal gain to slow parad
Dimension creation and prevent the ZK
class cross reality failure event in
stage one of operation minimal gain the
foundation began with neutralizing and
decommissioning all of their contained
anomalies under the classification of
uid or ker specifically those that were
expensive to contain or requiring high
levels of personnel and researchers
stage two saw operation castling be
commenced the r42 SCP Foundation
launched Rockets with variant SE Global
amnestic dispersing warheads and took
control over all countries in order to
hold power over all humankind in stage
three the foundation began to move their
world to a more natural state destroying
all hazardous radioactive chemical and
bacteriological objects removing dams
and stopping oil extractions during
stage three stage 4 began the r42 SCP
Foundation began eliminating Humanity in
third world countries by use of viral
and biological attacks stage five was a
widespread attack on Humanity where the
SCP Foundation added deactivate
resistant viral agents to water
treatment and collection plants food
products medication and household items
of developed countries by stage six only
.1% of humanity remained and they were
targeted with drone strikes or put into
concentration camps for elimination
stage seven of the remaining survivors
the foundation sampled them to find the
fittest of those left to preserve
humankind stage 8 saw 15,000 of these
people put into indefinite cryosleep and
the remaining survivors were eliminated
Stage Nine saw the destruction of the
remaining SCP Foundation Personnel we
move on to a list of proposals that were
made before or during operations
castling and minimal gain proposals
rejected include the use of SCP objects
or other Technologies to eliminate
derivative Dimensions the development of
Nanobots with the capability to control
human decision-making capabilities and
eliminate variability full replacement
of humanity with bionic hybrid acting
explicitly within standard behavioral
models unification of humanity into a
neural network with control given to an
AI Control unit and the destruction of
Earth Andor all of its inhabitants well
most of these seem like Clear Solutions
that would prevent the elimination of
humanity at the SCP foundation's hand
these proposals were all rejected for
one reason the SCP Foundation did not
have enough time one proposal was
accepted however the use of SCP P
000000 this appears to be the solution
the r42 SCP Foundation concocted to
fight SCP 001 and potentially save the
Multiverse it poses the question if the
r42 SCP Foundation used the same anomaly
to contain SCP 001 as proven by the fact
they no longer exist will PD do the same
the file explains that the r42 SCP
Foundation opened a dimensional Wormhole
into PD
as they do not know at the time if parad
Dimensions could cause the creation of
more parad dimensions in doing this the
SCP Foundation seemingly infected PD
with the ability to create parad
Dimensions the author of this file goes
on to explain that the r42 SCP
Foundation had plans to attack PD and
use operations castling and minimal gain
in the dimension however they could not
access the dimension again and they
believe that the foundation Personnel of
PD would have made use of th FAL class
anomalies to save themselves and their
world a note from R 42's overseer
council is left for PD if the apolon
destruction was not enough the overseer
council is involved the importance of
the neutralization of this anomaly
cannot be forgotten so the overseer
Council explained to PD the world has
existed before us and must remain after
us our Multiverse is ill and the name of
the illness is humanity SCP
001 the only way out is SCP
00000000 will cease to become a threat
with its help it is in our power to
leave a chance for other Sapient species
that perhaps will not be affected by the
same anomaly or we'll find a way to get
rid of it before it's too late we the 05
Council and other survivors from r42
have chosen Our Fate we hope you will do
the same same what is this SCP
000000 how did the SCP Foundation of r42
find the solution the file for SCP
00000000 is placed within this SCP 001
file SCP
000000 is a paradox Thal class anomaly
without any containment procedures
SCP is a device that once activated will
destroy the universe it was activated in
it will also destroy all parad
Dimensions that are not creating other
parad dimensions as such PD would not be
destroyed however the billions or
trillions of other par of Dimensions the
r42 parent Dimension created will be
destroyed PD is left with a harrowing
decision to continue living or destroy
itself to save the rest of the
Multiverse in the file a note from r42s
Jan Simpson is written for an SCP
Foundation overseer
05- one as part of operations castling
and minimal gain the remaining
Foundation employees were allowed one
family member to uphold morale Joan is
not writing for r42s
051 instead she's writing for PDS
051 this Dimensions version of her
father she begins with wondering whether
she can call this version of
remembers the day the foundation
employees were allowed to choose that
one family member they would save for
the time being her father was opposed to
allowing two family members as he
claimed it would cause unnecessary
stress and schisms among the remaining
few hundred Foundation staff 05-11 chose
to have Joan over her mother and she
understood everything by the look in his
eyes and grew angry but that feeling is
long gone now she began to work with her
father and the remaining Foundation
Personnel that called themselves
hostages behind the backs of those
higher up the ranks on day she felt sad
Joan and her father would go up to the
surface of the Earth in hazmat suits
sitting on the grass and watching over
the empty City at the bottom of the
mountain no Humanity remained with the
only life she could see being Birds her
father promised her that they'd return
there and build a giant Monument to
humanity at the center of the city she
knew this was a lie remembers when
someone proposed that they should open a
portal the one that opened to PD this
was their fatal mistake as after that
the parad dimension began replicating
parad Dimensions the countdown went down
to months again and the promise he made
to his daughter became impossible 0 5-1
died and left the position vacant Jan
says to the PD's 05 D1 that she doesn't
care whether they destroy their world or
not or whether the universe will
continue to exist or if there will be
new life in it her world was crushed
long ago the note also reads the
following it's good that this message is
encrypted with your key that was passed
on to me or these lines would have been
deleted everyone wants to save the world
but who needs it like this empty and
cold without those to appreciate its
beauty without Humanity do whatever you
think is right I truly feel better now
love you Faithfully Yours Joan Simpson
we're not too sure if PD went through
with destroying their Universe to save
the Multiverse but it seems that
whatever decision was made would cause
the destruction of that Universe whether
that be through the use of SCP
000000 or the ZK class cross reality
failure event Humanity will cease but
maybe if they make the decision to use
SCP
000000 Sapient life can begin to exist
again and hopefully no parad Dimensions
will be made from their decision
decisions decisions are an extremely
innate part of humanity you decided to
get out of bed this morning you decided
to open up your computer or phone and
you decided to watch this video who
knows the amount of parad Dimensions we
may have created today but in our world
we're not at risk but in the SCP
foundations Universe anything can be
anomalous even Humanity stop me if
you've heard this one before a young man
was driving home from work late one
rainy night when he spotted a woman in a
white dress and a red sweater walking
along the shoulder of the road concerned
for her safety he slowed down and rolled
down the window so he could talk to her
when he asked where she was going she
said she was walking to her parents'
house the man pulled over and offered
her a ride that she accepted the woman
gave him the address of her home hopped
in the back seat and the man drove off
he sensed that she must have been cold
from walking in the rain so he cranked
up the car's heater to help her dry off
soon she removed her heavy red sweater
and placed it on the seat next to her
the man tried to make friendly
conversation asking if the woman had a
job what she was studying at school
where'd she been that day but she
remained quiet staring out the window
until they drove past an old graveyard
the woman began pounding on the glass of
the car as if she desperately wanted
something unsure of what to do the man
pulled over but before he could ask her
what was happening she had gotten out of
the car he exited the car to try and
find her but the woman was nowhere to be
seen she must have somehow ran off
confused the man got back in his car and
drove away he went on his way and didn't
think of it again until the next day
when he noticed her sweater was still in
the back of his car he decided to go to
the house she had originally given him
the address for and give it back to her
he found the home without any trouble
but when he knocked on the door the old
woman who answered it was confused by
his story she she told him that her
daughter couldn't have possibly left her
sweater in his car because she died in a
car accident 30 years ago the vanishing
hitchhiker is a classic ghost story with
the details varying from place to place
and Storyteller to Storyteller in
Chicago she goes by Resurrection Mary
named after the graveyard she asks for
rides to in okanawa Japan she's known as
the night walker of Nago and she only
appears to taxi drivers in Kent England
she's Suzanne a bride killed in a car
wreck on the way to her bachelorette
party in North Carolina her name is
Lydia and in Hawaii she's believed to be
the goddess Pelle in human form but as
far as our friends at the SCP Foundation
are concerned the vanishing hitchhiker's
name is Mary talish also known as SCP
1337 on the 19th of May 1952 College
sophomore Mary talish was abducted on
her way to class in her hometown of Muny
Indiana when police found her body 2
week Weeks Later her eyes and heart had
been torn from her body in a ritualistic
fashion and she had scrapes and bruises
that suggested she had been beaten
before her murder her killers were never
caught and her body was returned to her
family for burial intance in Cemetery
starting on the 19th of June that same
year someone matching Mary's description
a Caucasian woman with blonde hair
standing 150 cm tall and wearing a red
sweater was spotted trying to flag down
passing Vehicles along Mayflower Road
since then every month on the 19th Mary
has been cited along that stretch of
road and every month the same scenario
plays out Mary gives anyone who picks
her up directions to her parents' house
then on the way she instructs the driver
to stop at the graveyard where she was
buried she vanishes from the car leaving
her sweater the driver of the car tries
to return the sweater to her parents'
house only to be told that Mary talish
was dead when the SCP Foundation was
made aware of of Mary tales's pattern of
Haunting in the late 50s they set up a
system where agents would Patrol
Mayflower Road at hourly intervals with
the intention of picking Mary up agents
were sent on their own in non-foundation
cars and instructed to stick to the
accepted script of the vanishing
hitchhiker Legend without attempting to
engage Mary in further conversation
Mary's parents were also given E-class
agent status to keep them from speaking
about the haunting and told that the
foundation was working on a way to set
the spirit har rest early attempts to
study The Apparition were inconclusive
it proved impossible for the foundation
to relocate her or trigger her
manifestation outside of the 19th of
every month and attempts to analyze her
sweater were fruitless since if the
sweater wasn't returned to the talish
family home it would simply vanish from
containment at or around sunset on the
next 19th for 20 years SCP 1337 events
continued to happen as normal d-class
Personnel under the instruction of of
the foundation would pick Mary up drive
her past the cemetery and return her
sweater to her parents it was business
as usual and in fact it was one of the
more sedate reoccurring apparitions the
foundation had to deal with but as you
might have guessed that piece wouldn't
last forever enter Dr Lawson who in 1972
was placed in charge of all resources
regarding SCP
1337 Dr Lawson was getting sick of all
this Phantom hitchhiker business and
while most of the foundation was happy
to keep this routine going Lawson
thought that the continual picking up
and dropping off of Mary talish and her
red sweater was a waste of the
foundation's valuable time after all it
was the early '70s the price of oil was
at an alltime high so the expense of
sending car after car up and down the
same road for a solid day once a month
just to pick up a ghost was more trouble
than it was worth so Lawson started
developing a plan one that he didn't go
through the proper Foundation channels
to approve he reasoned that the reason
Mary's ghost kept coming back was
because she wanted something since
always asked for a ride home then it
must mean she wanted to return back to
her parents so logic followed that if
she had nothing or no one to go back to
then she'd stop appearing on the 18th of
June
1973 Lawson went ahead with his plan
without his superior's knowledge and
ordered the execution of Mary tales's
parents as well as the immediate
demolition of their family home
according to his journals Lawson had
hoped that his attempt at
decommissioning 1337 would significantly
cut the foundation's gas bills freeing
up valuable funds at which point he'd
surely be promoted in recognition of his
Brilliance but that wasn't what happened
Lawson was demoted from team leader to
junior staff and only kept on 1337
detail out of the belief that without a
family to return to Lawson would become
the new focal point of the haunting
should Mary talish ever return the
Lawson's actions weren't at all above
board even by a SCP Foundation standards
they did seem to have worked the 19th of
June came and went without a single Mary
sighting and she wasn't seen the next
month either a full year went by without
any sign of the Mayflower Road
Apparition satisfied with this turn of
events the foundation made the decision
to officially reclassify SCP 1337 from
safe to Safe decommissioned and the gas
money that was budgeted for the
Mayflower Road Patrol was redirected to
the SCP 682 tank acid fund but even
though everything seemed to have been
sorted out Lawson wasn't entirely
satisfied and not just because of his
demotion whether it was Intuition or
merely guilt induced paranoia is unclear
but he suspected that Mary was still out
there somewhere at first he thought that
she might show up on the anniversary of
her parents' deaths but then that date
came and went as did eight more
anniversaries after it finally on the
19th of June 1983 Lawson decided he had
to see for himself fitted with recording
equipment he drove alone in a
non-foundation standard car down that
lonely stretch of road where so many
before him had stopped to pick up that
mysterious blonde woman with the red
sweater he had to prove to himself that
she wouldn't show up that he had really
and truly gotten rid of her for good it
was about 5:00 in the evening when he
reached Mayflower Road and first he
didn't experience anything strange he
scanned the roadside looking for the
Phantom hitchhiker walking along it but
there was nobody there Dr Lawson
breathed a sigh of relief he may have
orchestrated the deaths of two innocent
people but at least it hadn't been for
nothing he turned on the recorder he
brought with him and logged that nothing
had happened SCP 1337 had been
permanently neutralized as he approached
the T intersection and prepared to turn
onto Marsh Avenue he looked up to adjust
his rearview mirror to his horror he
found that he wasn't alone in the car
someone was in the seat behind him
someone with blonde hair and a red
sweater his last transmission consisted
only of wait who the hell are you before
the recording abruptly stopped Lawson's
car was found soon after by Foundation
agents Lawson was dead in the front seat
bruised and bloody with his eyes and
heart ripped out in a ritualistic
fashion just the way Mary talish had
been found all the way back in 1952 it
turns out that Mary hadn't been
neutralized after all she'd just been
waiting for a chance to get revenge on
the man who killed her family and Mary
didn't stop with Dr Lawson no longer
does she appear walking along the road
waiting for someone to offer her a ride
before disappearing without incident now
should someone pass by without offering
a ride she will appear in their back
seat before reenacting the method of her
own death upon the driver and her
physical appearance has changed changed
too whereas before she looked like the
image of a pretty young woman before her
tragedy now recording show that she
appears with the wounds of her death
present her eyes gouged out in their
sockets and a massive hole in her chest
where her heart should be the same
wounds she inflicts on her victims the
SCP Foundation has tried closing off and
eventually destroying the road but that
has only resulted in Mary manifesting at
other locations in and around Muny
Foundation documents reveal that any
Back Road in the city can potentially
serve as host to a 1337 event and all
attempts to contain The Apparition have
failed the only way someone who has seen
Mary can avoid her wrath is by stopping
to pick her up at which point she will
dematerialize before reappearing on
another road mobile task forces have
been unsuccessful as Mary only appears
to those driving alone and all agents
who have been sent on solo missions to
apprehend her have resulted in the death
of the agent SCP 1337 was reinstated
this time as uclid class currently the
foundation's method of managing SCP 1337
is to dispatch a security team on the
19th of every month to monitor all the
places where a potential sighting could
take place as soon as signs of a
manifestation are identified a remotely
controlled vehicle containing a single D
class is driven to the location once
Mary appears in the car the car is
piloted to the empty lot where her home
used to stand and the remains of the
d-class are then disposed of like a lot
of the stories that could pass down as
urban legends the story of SCP 1337 has
a lesson that can be taken away from it
this SCP started off as an ordinary
local haunting no more deadly than Lydia
Suzanne Resurrection Mary or any of the
countless other local versions of the
vanishing hitchhiker story but thanks to
one Rogue Foundation doctor and his
desire to rush what he thought would be
an efficient solution the spirit not
only became harder to control but also
much more violent and bloodthirsty than
anyone was prepared to deal with so if
there's anything we can learn here it's
that no matter if you're a student an
office worker or a researcher with the
SCP Foundation think twice about cutting
Corners it might save you a little bit
of time and money in the short term but
in the long term the results could be
fatal if you have ever taken a trip to
suntop mountain in the Mount Baker snow
qualy National Forest Washington State
then you may have come across an old
wooden structure the suntop fire lookout
built in the early 1930s the building
was used by the US Forest Service to
keep watch for any fires in the nearby
Woodland at one point suntop fire
lookout would have been mmed 365 days a
year complete with a bed for staff who
were stationed there on rotation the
single story Lookout house overlooks the
scene valleys of the White River and
Huckleberry Creek but you're not here
for an informative tourist guide you
probably don't care about the frankly
fascinating history of the lookout and
how it was used as part of the aircraft
warning service during World War II
watching for enemy Plains no you're here
because something much darker lurks
inside the suntop fire lookout and even
though it appears to be a simple
one-story tall wooden structure it
certainly is not short on Space SCP 3333
refers to an anomaly that the foundation
discovered inside the suntop fire
lookout house the building's interior is
a single Square Room measuring 14 ft by
14 ft with large windows on all four
sides when standing inside suntop fire
lookout looking up at the wooden ceiling
one will immediately notice a trap door
no big deal right a lot of places have a
ceiling entrance to a small CR crawl
space there's probably nothing behind
that trapo apart from a Dusty old attic
there's a latch that maybe once had a
padlock there but not anymore opening
the trap door will reveal a collapsible
ladder should anyone be brave or indeed
foolish enough to begin to climb then
they'll soon find themselves right back
where they started inside suntop fire
lookout or so it will see the thing
about being in a place like the Mount
Baker snow quami National Forest that
surrounds suntop fire lookout is that
Woodland areas are teeming with life not
just plants and trees but birds and
other animals of the forest you can
never truly be alone in a setting like
that there is always life everywhere
around you so when you ascend the ladder
and climb right back into the suntop
fire lookout that is the first most
noticeable difference you will find it
may take a while at first but the
nagging absence of something unusual
usually so abundant in a forest will
eventually become obvious it's quiet far
too quiet no bird song or the sound of
distant calls from Woodland Critters
just silence all around anyone ascending
the ladder will find themselves in a
copy of suntop fire lookout's interior
one story higher than the ground level
of the small wooden building with the
stairs leading up to the front door
getting taller each time to reach up to
the higher and higher building now you
know the SCP Foundation and the types of
bizarre interdimensional anomalies that
they're used to dealing with perhaps SCP
3333 is a mirror Dimension or a plane of
existence where sound doesn't travel it
certainly seems to be identical to the
suntop fire lookout save for the lack of
any organic life outside of course it's
what you'll find living inside SC SCP
3333 that you may want to worry about
climbing higher up the next next ladder
and through the next trapo every time
with the same result you appear at
another copy of suntop fire lookout each
one higher up than the last what first
seemed to be an innocuous unassuming
wooden building is now an endless
Ascension up into the heavens towards
the unknown in silence without a shred
of plant or animal life outside as you
climb perhaps you start to think about
how much higher these copies go this
might even be the biblical Jacob's
Ladder connecting Heaven and Earth that
would be nice wouldn't it if you were
gradually climbing your way up to
Paradise it might make it worth the trip
but SC SCP 3333 is nothing that Pleasant
you wouldn't be the first to attempt
this long climb when the SCP Foundation
first discovered a SCP 3333 a research
detail set up an on-site base camp to
examine this spatial anomaly their first
exploration involves sending a member of
d-class personnel designated d4f 68a up
the ladder his D number is a heximal
code that when translated to text reads
o so we'll call him that for brevity
sake during the first day's exploration
o was able to climb 184 iterations of
SCP
3333 communicating with head researcher
Dr Williams Below on the second day o
could see a pair of figures standing
motionless on a nearby Ridge but the
pair could not be seen by Dr Williams
and the other researchers at the base
camp
both figures disappeared shortly after o
spotted them with the camera he had been
issued and he felt uneasy almost certain
that he saw them point at him the next
day at the 345th copy of suntop fire
lookout O's Behavior started to
noticeably change previously he had been
anxious about the long climb and hadn't
questioned directions given to him by Dr
Williams now he seemed to speak more
casually resisting instructions asking
Williams to climb back down and even
calling her doc instead of doctor o also
reported seeing writing on the walls but
there was no evidence of this on his
camera it appeared that something had
started to affect him it was when o
reached level 527 that things seemed to
change more dramatically rather than SCP
3333 continuing upwards the copies of
suntop fire lookout no longer had a trap
door or ladder they seemed to be
arranged side by side side in a
grid-like pattern stepping out of the
main doorway o remarked on the lack of
sunlight and a walkway that connected
directly to the front door of the next
iteration of SCP
3333 o complained about the lack of
natural light and again requested to be
allowed back down Dr Williams instructed
o to use the flashlights he was provided
but they wouldn't activate and their
spare batteries had vanished O then
noticed a sudden movement and just then
his microphone and camera feed went dead
almost as if someone had turned them off
it appeared that SCP 3333 had something
else lurking up there Dr Williams
oversaw the second Expedition into SCP
3333 this time members of mobile task
force mod zero also known by the code
name characteristic eggan spaces were
sent up the ladder they sent through the
various copies of suntop fire lookout
were not as eventful as o with no signs
of mysterious figures or anxious
feelings that o seemed to feel as he
climbed when they reached level
527 where the copies of the lookout sto
progressing upwards and spread out in a
pattern instead their lights and
Equipment all seemed to be in working
order however as the MTF team split up
one by one they encountered some sort of
anomaly or an effect of SCP 3333 that
caused each of them to vanish into the
dark either that or something took them
these these MTF units reappeared
confused and mod 5 the team's leader
Graham purcel issued an order to retreat
and the entire Squad went back down the
ladders for several days until they
finally reached the base camp again the
members of mod zero were adamant they
did not wish to climb SCP 3333 again but
Dr Williams was beginning to understand
more of the anomalies of facts it
appeared to cause abrupt changes to
people's personalities along with some
sort of phenomenon that caused things to
appear and disappear The Higher One clim
assuming these were the result of a
mimetic effect Dr Williams dispatched a
counter mtic specialist for the next
Expedition this specialist was a blind
deaf and mute woman known as Annette or
the null Walker who communicated via a
signaling system embedded in her hand
but was otherwise immune to any mimetic
influences observed by Dr Williams and
Graham purcel at base camp a net made
her way to the top of SCP 3333 reporting
that she was aware of someone watching
her from outside the copies of suntop
fire lookout on her body camera a
flicker of motion occurred something
looking through the windows that ducked
out of frame when the camera passed in
its direction at the Apex of SCP 3333
Annette kept her flashlight off but
reported that she could detect blood
following it to what she assumed was a
body sounds of movement surrounded her
and as a nette switched on her
flashlight Williams and purcel saw that
it wasn't a body in front of her instead
it was a pile of rotting organs
decomposing muscles and discarded bones
and among the pile was a metal dog tag
that read MTF mod 5 gam Perell the same
man who was sitting next to Dr Williams
at base camp well the same man on the
outside at least the explanation for
everything going on inside SCP 3333 all
these strange occurrences and
disappearances finally came in a video
sent from Dr Williams's cell phone in it
a panicked Williams covered in blood was
fleeing from something at the top of the
recursive stack of SCP
3333 there was no mimetic effect at the
apex of the suntop fire lookout copies
nothing was causing the people that the
foundation sent up to act unlike
themselves they simply weren't
themselves anymore according to her
frantic video Dr Williams had discovered
the truth about what else was hiding
within SCP
3333 with just the right amount of
vagueness and Intrigue the research team
had been drawn in it was as if they'd
been lured in by the lights of an angler
fish realizing their Grim fate only too
late the d-class O the MTF team even a
net had been replaced an unknown group
of entities on the top level of SCP 3333
had been carefully observing them
waiting until they would not be seen to
slip in and switch places these entities
had been creating imagined anomalous
effects like oh seeing figures that
weren't really there as a way of luring
more bodies further up the stack they
wanted the foundation to keep sending
Expeditions into SCP
3333 to keep them coming back the mass
of organs musculature and bones that a
nette had stumbled across Reve revealing
the ruse had once belonged to Graham
purcel before he was replaced you see
the entities residing in SCP 3333
weren't just copying people they weren't
possessing them or mind controlling them
or even shapeshifting to steal a
person's likeness they were taking skin
these creatures hollowed out Graham o
Annette and the MTF team pulling out
their innards and crawling their way
inside filling these fleshy puppets and
leaving their internal organs to rot
these hollowed out people became vessels
for the entities of SCP 3333 to hide in
the whole thing had been a trap
intentionally exploiting human
weaknesses Intrigue and unanswered
questions you know what they say about
curiosity and these entities used it to
bring more potential vessels to the top
of SCP
3333 they pretended to be the people who
they had placed imitating them so the
foundation would send more Personnel to
explore the tower increasing their
supply of skins Graham's dog tag had
revealed the deception and Dr Williams
had escaped up SCP
3333 the members of the research team
that had already been replaced were hot
on her tail determined to catch and
Hollow her out too and by the end of her
video they had succeeded a month later
though A Team delivering supplies
realized what had happened and the trap
door was sealed suntop fire lookout was
put under permanent guard but at least
50 Personnel were killed or replaced by
one of the entities a new mobile task
force Lambda 1 Maxwell's demons was
created to hunt down and neutralize any
of the entities that had escaped SCP
3333 but it's still unknown how many
left the tower and are still out there
somewhere waiting to use someone's
curiosity about this strange and unknown
against them an organization with as
many Secrets as the SCP Foundation
requires the ability to dispose of
material that could prove harmful to the
facade of normaly that the 05 Council
desperately wishes to uphold and because
most of the high-ranking researchers are
a bit too smart and practical to Simply
flush classified documents and unwanted
objects down the toilet that means the
foundation has to get rid of evidence
thorough enough to guarantee that
absolutely no trace of what needs to be
disposed of Dove survives for this
purpose several waste disposal plants
are used as front companies for the
foundation and function internally as a
foolproof way to liquidate hazardous
material and comprising information but
not all secrets are so easily forgotten
with the push of a button and a rare few
can prove too resilient to be burned
away this is the regrettable case of the
anomalies contained within the site now
designated scp2
419 a place where the unfortunate
consequence of amnestic experiments has
led to the creation of hateful Immortal
humanoids faded to be sealed within the
incinerators of the facility these
Undead freaks are known as SCP 2419 daa
and though they were made from human
bodies the Consciousness that dwells
within each instance is nothing short of
Pure Evil every happy memory and
Associated positive emotion was
extracted from the brains of SCP 24198
corpses prior to their attempted
disposal in the incinerators this was
done in order to increase the
effectiveness of standard issue
Foundation amnestics but the cost of
this minor breakthrough was that these
bodies all of which were once d-class
Personnel had effectively been stripped
of all human qualities given the sorts
of violent criminal backgrounds that
earns an individual the designation of
d-class person
these former humans were the last people
that should have been deprived of the
love and joy in their hearts and when
the first of these Psychopathic laughing
men crawled out of one of SCP 241 19's
incinerators the foundation learned all
too well what an uninhibited Criminal
Mind looked like driven only by rage and
fury that inspired their most gruesome
acts of exploitation and violence in
life their pain has made them too
hateful to succumb to the flame names
they are the archetypal Sinners of a
burning hell that the foundation's best
intentions pave the road to and when
they break loose all that Hell Breaks
Loose with them but no place of the dam
leaves its Gates unguarded Dante's
Inferno posits that the ancient Greek
mythological figure Minos Serpentine
father of the minor and judge of wicked
Souls guards the pit of Hell with Stern
vigilance the Greeks themselves favored
the image of curus a three-headed Hound
that served its Lord Hades as a watchdog
for the ancient Egyptians there was AMU
the Devourer of the Dead who consumed
the hearts of the unrighteous in the
afterlife while this sort of guardian
beast is not officially on the
foundation's payroll the concept turned
out to be alive and well in the present
day when SCP 682 the hard to destroy
reptile stood against the Laughing men
and gave them the fight of their
tortured unliving existence it all began
when the guards stationed at SCP 2419
began to hear banging from inside one of
the incinerators it seemed as though the
SCP
2419 instance on the other side was
determined to breach containment so
mobile task force beta 7 the MZ Hatters
were called into stand with all weapons
at the ready but this was exactly what
the instance wanted as soon as the Armed
Force had fully assembled The Laughing
Man inside ripped the door from its
hinges it proceeded to use it as a cover
and run full speed towards the mobile
task force who opened fire immediately
SCP 2419 Das a were known to possess
extremely fast regenerative abilities so
it would take a lot of punishment to
slow this instance down but this was no
unthinking zombie and the instance broke
its charge the second it was in the
midst of the mobile task force agents to
twirl the door around like a trained
martial artist this not only sent the
incoming bullets ricocheting everywhere
causing many of the beta 7 operatives to
be hit by their own friendly fire it
also allowed the instance to bludgeon
several agents with sides of the door as
the remaining mobile task force members
retreated to a less exposed vantage
point where they could employ Heavy
Artillery the instance used this moment
of confusion to pitch the Door backwards
towards the incinerators in a boomerang
trajectory the force and spin of the
door knocked two more incinerator doors
off their hinges and caused two other
instances of SCP 2419 daa to emerge one
who was so thoroughly decomposed that it
appeared to be more than a flaming
skeleton sprinted forth and threw
handfuls of hot Cinders at the
foundation agents it used its still
burning body to ignite a few of the
closest agents laughing with sadistic
Glee as it did so seconds after the
emergence of the two new instances a
grenade launcher was fired at the first
escapee the blast was enough to deal
significant damage but the instance was
indifferent to its own pain it pointed
to the agent wielding the grenade
launcher and a moment later the third
instance was at the agent's throat
strangling him to death it was starting
to become clear to the mobile task force
that this was no random Containment
Breach it was a coordinated escape
attempt by three ruthless criminal
masterminds who in their time contained
at the site SCP 2419 had probably
decided there was some truth to the old
adage that misery loves company and
indeed these three class were some of
the best of the best when it came to
being the worst of the worst
d576 formerly police Lieutenant Campbell
farage a riot cop with a serious taste
for Carnage whenever the streets of the
city Precinct he presided overturned
violent farage always made sure that the
violence didn't die down too quickly his
nasty pension for bludgeoning suspects
and citizens alike with his riot shield
did wonders for the Escape Plan he had
coordinated with his fellow laughing men
he was eventually tried and sent to a
supermax after picking a fight with
several other officers in the line of
duty a fight that resulted in a pair of
rookie officers who opposed his violent
methods being hospitalized with
permanent Comas the skeleton was D
4483 Damen Lambert a prolific arsonist
who terrorized Three Counties while
avoiding detection under the guise of
being a sovereign citizen if there was
ever a person who wanted just to watch
the world burn it was Damen Lambert he
was caught in the process of setting
fire to an elementary school and was
thankfully apprehended before any of the
kerosene he had poured through the Halls
ignited when the truth about his
previous history of Pyromania came out
Lambert faced death row until the
foundation chose to recruit him as
d-class then there was
d236 Arnold rooper who was better known
as the Illinois Strangler responsible
for over 50 deaths in two decades before
he was arrested and detained while he
mostly used his bare hands to do the
deed rer was fond of using metal chains
and heavy duty choke collars usually
worn by animals to perform his namesake
act of violence rer wasn't just brutally
strong he was crafty too and the trio of
laughing men had him to thank for some
of the finer points of the Escape Plan
the three now Immortal D class also had
one thing in common each of them had met
the ends of their cruel and violent
lives the jaws and Claws of SCP 682 and
now that they had outmaneuvered and
slaughtered mobile task force beta 7
their only Collective goal was to get
revenge on the monster that condemned
them all to the fiery hell of the
incinerator The Laughing men soon
breached the limits of the SCP 2419
containment site and began making their
way Overland towards the facility where
all of them had met their original fate
they knew they needed Wheels to get
there so the instit es made their way to
the nearest gas station from the waste
disposal plant they'd come from and made
short work of the staff Lambert stocked
up on lighters kerosene and Duraflame
while farage took the emergency shotgun
that the cashier hadn't had time to fire
in her defense it would have been
difficult to accomplish much of anything
with Roper's hands clasped around her
throat once the trio of Undead
Psychopaths had stocked up on weapons
they waited for a suitable vehicle to
pull into the lot and before long there
was a family SUV with a happy family
inside no less verage ordered Lambert to
keep his fire starting tendencies in
check as a gas station explosion was the
last thing they needed right now the
former riop made his way out to the car
and used the shotgun to threaten the
family out of the car family road trips
can be stressful but rarely does one
expect to be carjacked by a gang of the
undead verage told the Unlucky Mortals
that he wouldn't hurt them if they let
let himself and his two friends use
their car and true to his word he didn't
fire a single shot the family were all
added to roer's list of victims instead
after that the three men took to the
wheel and with only their hazy memories
of pain and suffering to guide them
drove relentlessly towards the
foundation facility where their enemy
SCP 682 was contained the three had made
sure to leave no human alive at their
original containment site and would
allow no Witnesses who saw their an less
corpse-like forms to survive they
couldn't afford to give the foundation a
heads up that the Reckoning was on its
way in a family motor vehicle meanwhile
at the Laughing man's intended
destination SCP 682 was having another
perfectly routine day of painfully
soaking in a tank of corrosive acid this
was part for the course for the reptile
and it found itself as eager as anyone
else stuck in a rut to get a break from
the repetitive mundanity of containment
little did the human hating monster no
it would soon get its wish a few hours
later the facility was shocked to find
that several fires had been lit at the
fringes of the testing units these were
no freak accidents but rather the work
of Damen Lambert the arsonist still had
memories of all the times he wished he
could just burn his jailers buildings to
the ground and had targeted the most
vulnerable areas for combustion the
Flames threatened the Integrity of
several areas of the facility and
multiple containment breaches were
imminent if the blaze couldn't be C
under control while any available agents
with firefighting experience sought to
minimize the damage the researchers
evacuated to safer parts of the building
bringing any sensitive documents and
flammable items far away from the
affected sections this kind of
pandemonium was exactly where officer
farage thrived and he soon entered The
Fray causing enough commotion that rer
was able to slip deeper into the
facility completely undetected this
turned out to be the perfect role for
the Strangler as he hadn't eluded the
police for 20 years of his life just by
being lucky farage and Lambert would
both join up with him after they were
finished having their fun for now his
task was to locate the containment unit
of SCP 682 and give the Beast a taste of
what the trio had in store along the way
he made sure to obtain some durable
metal chains from a different
containment unit he likely released some
kind of Elder evil in the process but
rer didn't care about the consequences
the bottom line was that he was always
able to do his best work when he was
armed it wasn't long before he found the
large chamber which housed his most
hated foe SCP 682 roer laughed
maniacally as he approached the creature
floating in its acid tank remember me
lizard the Strangler said sporting a
wide grin The Monster simply growled
back at roer wishing to tear him apart
rer chuckled again and wrapped the iron
chains around the vat with all the
considerable strength of his imor mortal
muscles the Strangler pulled the chains
tot and shattered 682s containment unit
the anomalous chain snared the
creature's body holding it in place how
about now Rober taunted 682 he laughed
but the creature laughed back no said
the reptile I don't remember you but you
are
disgusting the monster lunged towards a
nearby wall and burst through dragging
Roper along with it by chains still
wrapped around the creature's body 682
twisted and turned flinging rer against
every wall and obstacle in sight but to
its surprise The Stranger was
regenerating and his grip on the chains
was unyielding back down the hall farage
was still continuing his Rampage when he
ran into an unlikely adversary Dr Alto
kleff stood between the Laughing Man and
the other researchers and as usual the
good doctor was packing heat he told the
other researchers to go on without him
while he contained the SCP 2419 instance
on his own a bold move to be sure but Dr
clef had made the same mistake he was
always making by assuming that guns were
the solution to this problem farage
laughed off the bullets and slammed into
Dr kleff with enough Force to leave a
crater in the wall behind him he
followed up with a merciless barrage of
punches beating the armed researchers
senseless and only relenting for a
moment to steal a few of his prized
firearms with a blow that would have
taken the life of any normal man farage
struck Dr kleff once more and left him
lying there a hair's length from Death
Dr clef's anti- anomaly field may have
protected him from reality warpers but
it did very little against being kicked
repeatedly very hard in the face
elsewhere Lambert had made his way into
the facility setting more fires as he
went the arsenous skeleton was a
terrifying sight to all that beheld it
and when the guards realized that none
of their weapons would have any effect
most of them started to run away from
Lambert rather than towards him all
three laughing men would soon be upon
682 and then the fight of their after
lives could truly begin until that
moment roer was buying his Partners in
hatred more time the chains he had
stolen were no ordinary metal and with
them he had managed to keep 682s Jaws
shut while he pounded away at its
exposed ribs with his inhuman strength
rer had killed more people than either
of his former d-class compatriots but
all that seemed to mean nothing in the
face of this invincible reptile the
shame and powerlessness he had once felt
as the creature had mauled him to death
made his Immortal heart beat with
outrage when he was alive the Illinois
stranger had always thought that his
gift for murder made him better than the
average person A man among men but this
thing had made him feel weak in his last
moments of humanity and that sickening
emotion of weakness was still sliding
around in his soul with all of the other
Despair and Malice if his fate were to
live forever as a dead man walking then
he would make damn sure that any
humiliation he suffered would be paid
back three-fold this soup of impotent
Fury bubbled within Roper as SCP 682
strength suddenly increased shattering
the weak link of the chains and sending
the hapless Strangler flying backwards
at that precise moment farage leaped out
of a nearby hallway and Unleashed Dr
cl's Arsenal on the reptile this
sustained fire irritated the creature
and it turned its focus towards the
unliving dirty cop it Reed a charge only
to be suddenly held fast by Roper who
had grabbed its tail barrage fired until
there was no more ammo then pistol
whipped the creature in both of its eye
sockets SCP 682 thrashed and struggled
so the men began to circle the reptile
and Alternate delivering formidable body
blows they took far more damage than
they could dish out with their bare
hands but the Regeneration that their
pratal hatred granted them meant that
both instances could theoretically keep
this up all day rer grabbed a broken
length of the anomalous chain while
farage picked up a metal table to use as
a makeshift riot shield the Beatdown
continued as 682s eyes regenerated along
with several new sensory organs to give
it a full 360° view of the pitched brawl
that was taking place a fiery explosion
blew open a nearby wall and in walk
Lambert still skeletal and laughing as
upro isly as ever he threw a Molotov
cocktail at 682s back causing the
creature to ignite immediately the
reptile roared in sudden Agony farage
Lambert Roper regrouped at the
creature's flank and pushed together
until they forced it back through the
hole where the arsonist had entered from
they were now all together in The
Inferno the three laughing men who
refused to die and the indestructible
monster that made them into what they
were were Roper quickly nodded the
chains and wrapped them around one of
the creatures claws securing the other
end around his waist like a trained
boxer he bobbed and weaved pummeling the
Beast with all he had any step back from
SCP 682 was met with the immortal man
shifting his entire body weight to pull
the creature's leg out from under it
barage wedged his shield into the
creature's Open Jaw widening it to an
uncomfortable degree and temporarily
limiting 682s bite force he took out the
shotgun that he had stolen from the gas
station and blasted it down the reptile
gullet when that plan had run its course
he started clubbing 682 about its neck
and head with the butt of the shotgun
Lambert simply continued to dowe the
arena with more flammable material
especially himself and the creature he
climbed on to 682s back with his burning
bones and hammered away at its defenses
with literal fists of fire the arsonist
was incapable of articulate speech due
to the damage to his body prior to his
death but if he could speak he would
probably be celebrating the fact that he
had become what he had always wanted to
be Damen Lambert was no mere Pretender
with a fetish for fire he was fire
itself a brightly burning God of
destruction that left no inch of the
world unburnt and no molecule of oxygen
unconsumed his mother and father would
be proud of him as they waited in hell
for the sun who would never arrive the
sun who would make the planet they left
behind into a true hell where he would
reign supreme that is until SCP 682
stole that dream out from under him with
a flash of blue and green from deep
within 682 began to burn with a neverbe
seen chemical reaction and impossible
event that could only be described as
anti-fire the turquoise anti Flames
devoured the orange and yellow ones
leaving Lambert in a state of panic
which was soon shared by his fellow
laughing men the three former declass es
had gotten so used to the torments of
the incinerator that the idea that
anything could be more painful had never
occurred to them and yet here it was the
anti-fire which devoured all flames and
directly inflicted unimaginable
suffering to the trio of instances every
particle of their still regenerating
bodies felt as if it were ice cold and
melting into nothingness at the same
time numbed and broken All Over Again
The Laughing men were consumed all over
by the anti flames and fell into a state
of suspended animation with the
foundation finally getting everything
back under control 24 hours later SCP
682 was contained in a new acidic
chamber there were some new ordinances
from all present and surviving
researchers about exposing it to fire as
the anti Flames It produced were
considered too hazardous to ever exist
within the facility again as for the
three laughing men who had escaped from
SCP 2419 they were returned to their
containment units inside of the
incinerators and never exhibited signs
of aggression or Escape attempts ever
again a psychological profile of farage
Lambert and Roper that all of them could
still feel the sting of the burns left
by 682s antifire to this day and that
not even exposure to Natural heat and
fire could ever reduce that pain
Russell's Back was pressed against the
wall his shuttering hands gripping the
fire axx the low emergency lighting
filling the corridor indicated the
lockdown was still in effect although
that was simultaneously a blessing and a
curse sure it meant that thing couldn't
get out hopefully but it also meant that
Russell was stuck in the wing of the
facility with it he had no idea if
anyone else was left he hadn't seen what
had happened to Carpenter maybe it got
him or perhaps he had managed to give it
the slip at the last second there was no
way of knowing for sure it had all
started so simply so innocently and with
such Noble intentions if he had known it
was would lead to all this madness
Russell would have never put his name
down on the request form the SCP
Foundation had been working on a way to
neutralize or cure SCP 610 for what felt
like forever to one team of scientists
the infamously so-called flesh that
hates was a fascinating organism it was
a highly contagious saric skin disease
isolated entirely within the small area
of Siberia that on its own wasn't enough
to Peak the interest of the research
team led by Dr Carpenter including his
handpicked star researchers Russell and
David along with their assistant clenon
and Dr Boton an expert on infectious
diseases who had recently joined their
efforts to provide his specialist
knowledge what did Captivate all of them
however was what SCP 610 did when it
infected a human being the disease would
trigger aggressive and uncontrollable
mutations within its infected and could
virtually rewrite their entire
physiology in a heartbeat the flesh that
hates was capable of transforming a
person's body into a horrifying fleshing
mass of Limbs and matter that barely
resembl the human being anymore and in
addition the infected individuals would
retain some level of awareness attacking
any uninfected person with extreme
hostility there had long been chatter
among some other research team studying
SCP 610 about devising a way to
weaponize the disease if they could
somehow create a variant that didn't
turn people into to monsters or at least
caused the fleshy Abominations to die
shortly after mutation then the
foundation or another interested party
could deploy the flesh that hates as a
biological weapon Dr Carpenter had long
abhor the idea instead searching for a
way to completely reverse the effects of
an SCP 610 infection it may have been
idealistic perhaps even naive by some
standards but the rest of his team was
behind him in the pursuit of that Noble
goal although not one of them knew it
would soon cost them their lives hitting
speed bump after speed bump in their
research the team were beginning to lose
hope researcher David was the most
outspoken in how tired he was of seeing
the same results yelling in frustration
that the flesh could not be cured by
conventional means however it was that
Outburst that gave Russell the idea they
had tried treating SCP 610 like a common
virus as if it was any other form of
disease largely thanks to Dr botton's
input and Ed that approach had taught
them a lot about the flesh's ability to
contaminate a subject from a single cell
but this infection was anomalous through
and through could the solution to
eradicating it for good lie not in a
medical cure but in another SCP Russell
brought this hypothesis to the rest of
the research team and each of them had
suggestions for other anomalies they
could potentially use to cure a subject
of the flesh that hates we could get SCP
049 to take a look at the infected
patient clinten suggested oh might work
Carpenter mused although even if he
kills someone he might also kill them he
has his whole deal about ridding the
world of the pestilence could prove to
be a problem uh there's always
682 David said dryly have the reptile
eat up all the SCP 610 infectees and
voila problem solved oh real helpful
David researcher Russell retorted and
what are we going to do when SCP 682
adapts to the flesh you really want an
infected Immortal lizard on the loose
Gentlemen please Dr botton spoke up
we're forgetting one obvious option I
propose we submit a joint formal
requests to use SCP 914 for this
experiment unanimously the group all
agreed that this was the best course of
action SCP 914 or the Clockworks was a
giant machine with two booths marked
input and output although the foundation
still couldn't fully comprehend exactly
how as CP 914 seemed to take any object
placed within it and disassemble
recreate improve or destroy the item
depending on its current setting there
was one issue however a prior failed
experiment wherein a d-class was placed
in SCP 914 had led to some pretty
disastrous consequences as a result ever
since no organic matter was to be placed
within the Clockworks a rule that the
team's experiment with the flesh would
breach still they pressed on each of the
five researchers signing their request
to utilize SCP 914 before it was
admitted to the foundation hups within
hours the request was denied but the
team was determined that SCP 914 could
be the key to solving the foundation's
long-standing issue with SCP 610 Dr
Carpenter repealed the decision urging
the hups to reconsider he argued that
this flouting of the no organic matter
rule was necessary to potentially rid
the world of the flesh that hates after
a few days of consideration the request
was finally fatefully granted the team
went to work immediately requisitioning
two test subjects both of which had
suffered SCP 610 infections and were
horribly mutated the pair of them were
deemed a potential Hazard to every
member of foundation staff on site and
as a result the entire wing of the
facility where the Clockworks was housed
had to be evacuated for safety dressed
in biohazard suits to protect themselves
the researchers used an electric cattle
prod to coax the first flesh specimen
into the input chamber of SCP 914 te
this was the test run they wanted to see
if the Clockworks would actually be able
to affect those infected with a SCP 610
at all plus they needed a fail safe just
in case something went wrong and luckily
the machine had just the thing Russell
asked clenon to set the Clockworks too
rough and with a click and were of its
numerous gears and Gyros SCP 914 came to
life instantly the infected test subject
was completely obliterated the setting
had reduced it to atoms disintegrating
it on such a microscopic level that
there was nothing left in the output
chamber the second infected creature
seemed to bristle with anger but didn't
attack or become aggressive as it too
was pted towards the Clockworks next
perhaps out of fear that their Theory
might be wrong the team agreed to set
SCP 914 to its one:1 setting sure enough
the machine recreated another instance
of a specimen infected with the flesh
that hates replacing the previous one we
all know we're stalling researcher David
piped up let's do what we came here for
set the Clockworks to course nervously
receiving a nod from Dr Carpenter
Clinton stepped forward to switch the
dial on SCP 914 to the course setting
this was the primary reason the team had
all agreed to use the machine on a flesh
specimen this setting could disassemble
any item placed in the input Booth
separating it into its base components
botton had suggested the use of SCP 914
based on the theory that if it worked
correctly the Clockworks could extract
the flesh that hates from its infected
host rendering them free of the disease
the machine made a colossal amount of
noise as Clinton hurried back to a safe
distance with the others but as it was
powering up seconds from activating Dr
Carpenter noticed something the color
drained from his face as he saw it none
of the others had noticed from a
distance that the dial hadn't been set
to course instead it pointed to very
fine the highest refinement setting 9914
had what the hell have you done
Carpenter yelled that clenon before the
machine suddenly activated would step
free from the output Booth stunned the
researcher it was a man a seemingly
ordinary human who had presumably been
infected by a SCP 610 some time ago he
stepped nervously out of the machine
looking confused for a moment as a pair
of foundation security guards cautiously
approached him we did it Russell said in
awe suddenly fleshy tendrils burst forth
from the man's arms latching on to the
approaching guards they screamed in
agony their bodies melting become a
bloody misshapen mass that stayed
attached to the humanoid creature at the
center it was like they became a part of
it the guards arms and legs forming
additional limbs as their forms were
reconstituted and repurposed as part of
a monster that was now crawling on its
six legs towards the research team in a
blind panic the group scrambled for the
entrance the head of the infected man
splitting open down the middle opening
up into a wide snapping pair of Jaws
panting hard as he ran his breath
fogging up the clear face plate of The
Biohazard suit Russell ran through the
door hearing someone close behind he
stopped for a moment looking back to see
the creature on the other side of the
door starting to spill through the door
frame like a liquid running faster
around the corner Russell came to
another halt in the common area a third
security guard following just before a
thick Steel security door came slamming
down sealing the creature on the other
side the other door didn't hold it what
good is that going to do researcher
David yelled more to the point Dr
Carpenter said turning and marching
towards clenon he launched a furious
punch at the assistant knocking him to
the floor why did you set 914 to very
fine clenon the enraged doctor shouted
you're the one who Unleashed that
Abomination you maniac what Clinton
replied fearfully trembling I I didn't I
swear I didn't it said course I'm sure
of it you expect us to believe that was
a mistake gentlemen we need to focus on
the situation at hand the security
officer interjected regardless of who's
responsible we need to inform the
foundation hups there's an emergency
lock down Russell replied it would have
triggered the moment the SCP 610
specimen got free you've trapped us with
a monster clenon Dr Carpenter spat hold
on researcher David spoke up wasn't it
boton's idea to use 914 in the first
place the common area fell silent as
everyone turned to look at Dr Boton did
you plan for this doc David pushed Boton
chuckled neat I remind you my friends
that we all agreed to use the Clockworks
did we not all of our names are on the
request he answered besides accusing me
David that's rather Rich coming from you
what's that supposed to mean the
researcher fired back beckoning his
finger Boton encouraged the rest of the
team to follow him across the common
area to where a row of lockers stood
each door bearing one of their names he
gestured to the one labeled David go on
Boton added shooting him a dirty look
David barged past the disease X and
opened his locker not one among the
group expected what would fall out it
was an old leatherbound book symbols
carved into the front cover instantly
thanks to the work studying SC SCP 610
the researchers all knew a text on
sarcasm when they saw one it had been
long known that the flesh that hates was
often described in texts revered by
saric Cults who worshiped death Decay
and disease what the hell David Russell
exclaimed picking up the book and
examining it in disbelief you're a
sarcast carpenter asked the fury in his
voice already elevating no I'm not
researcher David protested I've never
seen that before it was in your locker
the doctor yelled you're one of those
cannibal cultists this was your plan to
refine the flesh for your Twisted death
worshipping religion it certainly seems
that way Boton interjected after all
research of David did seem frustrated at
our earlier results impatient even you
David pointed at the doctor you planted
this in my locker you're here a sarcast
clenon repeated in a nervous stammer you
made me turn the dial to very fun you
made that thing of fear you made me your
accomplice anger tears streamed down his
face Clinton's hand reached for the
security officer's gun and went to draw
it planning to shoot David on the spot
but as he went to pull the weapon from
the guard's holster it wouldn't budge it
was then that assistant clenon stared in
horror at his hand his fingers had fused
to the guard's leg the officer gave a
twisted grin as his torso burst open
tendrils of Flesh latching onto clenon
and assimilating him just like it had
done before the flesh creature broke
down its victim's body making it a new
part of itself a grotesque mass of Limbs
and bloody matter littered with the
discarded faces of those it had infected
the research team looked at it terrified
their stomachs turning disgusted at the
growing growling abomination of bodies
fused to one another oh you're beautiful
Russell Heard a Voice whisper behind him
he turned to see bont looking at the SCP
610 creature and smiling researcher
David was the closest and the creature
lunged at him pulling his leg out from
under him screaming in fear the
researcher fell onto the ground and was
dragged towards the flesh it pulled him
in his body stretching skin tearing and
Bones snapping as he became part of it a
new set of Limbs added to the monster Dr
Carpenter went to try and pull him free
but it was already too late and he
stepped back knowing that if he touched
it he would would be infected too the
sound of running caught Russell's
attention and he spotted botton making a
break for it grabbing Dr Carpenter by
the sleeve the researcher pulled him in
the same direction partly running away
from the flesh as it assimilated David
and partly chasing the saric savitur the
pair of them quickly caught up to Boton
leaning over himself and panting
breathlessly thank God you two made it
he wheezed after the run I can't believe
David could do this to unleash this
nightmare Upon Us Russell thought to
snap at him to scream how dare he keep
lying but boton's back was to him now
he'd never get a better chance there was
a cabinet on the corridor wall
containing a fire axe for emergencies as
carefully and quietly as he could
Russell fished the axe out of its case
whilst spoton and carpenter were looking
away we should get the foundation to
lift the lock down Boton was saying they
need to let us out and
then he let out a blood curling scream
mids sentence as the ax blade wounded
him Russell pulled it back standing over
the doctor as he fell to the floor in
agony Russ have you lost your mind
Carpenter exclaimed no doctor he's the
cultist I have no idea how he tricked
clenon but that flesh creature exists
because of him the researcher answered
from the floor unable to move thanks to
his injury Dr botton began to laugh it
took me years to infiltrate the
foundation so much time waiting to gain
access to that blessed flesh he gled and
now you've helped me to refine it to
create its ultimate form you want to
kill me go ahead Russell my life doesn't
matter for once that creature is free it
will bring about a new age of Flesh and
Grand Caris iron will reward me for the
role I played in unleashing it David was
right Carpenter realized but you you've
planted that book on him to throw us off
doctor we need to think of something
researcher Russell interjected actx
still in hand nobody knows more about
the flesh that hates than us there must
be a way to kill that thing otherwise if
it gets out of this lockdown it could
spread to everyone in the foundation
what about fire that's been effective
against 610 infectees before right yes
yes but the doctor desperately tried to
think this new being we've created he
created Russell argued looking at the
grimacing wounded Boton we cannot deny
the role we've all played in this
researcher Carpenter argued and we have
no idea if it possesses the same
weaknesses as the flesh before its
refinement but we have to try sir the
researcher protested of course I agree
the sickening sound of a slithering
slick Mass was rapidly approaching still
laying on the floor in pain Dr botton
had been dragged to the middle of a
junction with Carpenter and Russell
hiding around either Corner suddenly
botton started hollering as the flesh
came into view practically calling it to
him oh look at you he exclaimed you're
better than I could have ever hoped for
looking down at him with the faces had
had collected the creature stamed one of
its disgusting appendages through Boton
drawing its body into its growing form I
am honored to give my life so that the
age of Flesh May begin the doctor said
weakly through the pain as he was
infected from around the corner
Carpenter had taken the saric text and
set its pages on fire with a cigarette
lighter turning to the creature he
hurled the mass of burning paper at it
hoping it would be enough fire to spread
to the flesh while it was assimilating
Boton who they had left there as bait
the fiery book collided with the
monstrosity as Russell peaked around the
corner he saw the flesh retreating from
from the Flames boton's body now added
to it for a moment it seemed like the
creature was afraid of the fire but
slowly it drew nearer and nearer to the
book with ease it stamped down the
Flames with botton's leg dowsing the
fire and suffering no damage to it at
all gripping the axe in his hands
Russell went to charge the creature only
to feel something push him back Dr
Carpenter had stopped him run he yelled
instantly Russell turned and raced down
the corridor the sound of fleshy
tentacles whipping through the air he
dared not look back just in case the
monster was right behind him eventually
he reached another corner and slammed
his back against it hand shuttering as
he held on to the fire axe he had no
idea what had happened to Carpenter
maybe it got him or perhaps he had
managed to give it the slip at the last
second Russell came a hush voice from
around the corner one the researcher
recognized he turned to see Dr Carpenter
approaching him sneaking like he was
trying to avoid being heard I think I
managed to give it the slip the doctor
whispered for a second Russell backed up
his hands tightening around the axe
handle this might have looked like Dr
Carpenter but was it are you really you
doctor he asked of course I am Carpenter
replied you don't think that I'm not
that monstrosity Russell raised the axe
defensively only to notice the sadness
in the doctor's face unable to bring
himself to swing even to find out the
researcher lowered his weapon Carpenter
looked grateful come on let's get them
to lift this lock down you said I'm sure
an MTF can step in and take care of our
mistake as the pair of them cautiously
made their way towards one of the locked
doors Dr Carpenter reached out a hand to
place it on Russell's shoulder ask
anyone that has been through it and
they'll all tell you the same that
moving home is maybe one of the most
stressful things that a normal person
can ever experience it's a logistical
nightmare right from the start the
moment you talk to a realtor about being
interested in selling your current house
and buying another everything goes
downhill from there after that moment an
avalanche of things comes hurling
towards you finding a place you like
making an offer letting people look
around your house waiting for them to
make a counter offer exchanging
contracts and that's before you even
have thought about packing and as Milo
had learned doing all of that on your
own only makes the stress of moving feel
all the more potent but he had finally
made it after a constant back and forth
with his realer the time had come for
him to pack up all of his worldly
possessions and relocate to a brand new
place to call home he had felt it was
long overdue for him to get a change of
scenery and luckily just the right place
had come onto the market to answer that
call it was a pretty big house bigger
than Milo's previous home but
considerably cheaper in fact he thought
it had been significantly undervalued
the house had an almost Victorian air of
feel to it all beautifully carved and
varnished Woodwork and creaky old
floorboards but in more of an elegant
refined sort of way rather than a
creepier one that's not to say Milo new
place wasn't without its more unsettling
elements aside from being big spacious
and easy to imagine as being haunted the
creepiest thing about the house aside
from its frighteningly low price was the
story of what happened to the previous
owners obviously you know that legally
we have to disclose whether or not
anyone died on this property the
realator had explained wearing a force
grin as she showed Milo around the house
hearing that sentence he could feel the
hairs on the back of his neck stand up
someone died here he asked in disbelief
no no no no of course not sir the
realtor instantly walked back her
statement Less in an effort to ease her
client's nerves but more to ensure that
she still closed the deal and earned her
commission bonus then why the hell would
you start a sentence like that Milo
asked we just have to give full
disclosure but I assure you the previous
residents didn't die on the grounds of
this house she gave that fake smile
again it was pretty ineffectual at
reassuring him
so what happened to the last owner well
it's a bit of a mystery to be honest a
local Legend if you like but hey that
gives the place more flavor hearing some
spooky history right think of what a
conversation starter that will be the
realator ended her sentence with a
forced snorting laugh but rained it back
in when she realized Milo wasn't
laughing with her ah as far as I know
there used to be an older couple living
here the Shaws they were apparently very
quiet reclusive kept to themselves a lot
I'm sure you know the typ Milo couldn't
help but notice she shot him a look as
she said that part as if she was
silently passing judgment on the fact he
was planning on moving in alone but they
used to spend a lot of time tending the
garden out front so their neighbors
would see them pretty frequently which
meant they were all okay and no one had
any bad mishaps in the house you know
how old folks can be such a worry when
they get to that age yeah totally Milo
interjected aware the realator was
stalling he repeated so what actually
happened to them well that's the thing
she Shrugged Nobody Knows the full story
one day the neighbors across the street
noticed they hadn't seen Mr and Mrs Shaw
for quite a while so naturally they came
on over here to see if they were in and
the last thing they wanted was to assume
everything was hunky dory here I mean
hey better save them sorry right but
once they got inside they couldn't find
either of them Mr and Mrs Shaw were just
gone vanished Without a Trace most
people on the street thought they had
just sold the place kept it quiet and
moved away retired to somewhere nice and
exotic Oh well that sounds nice I
suppose Milo replied relieved to hear
that there hadn't been any brutal
unsolved murders in the house and that
it most likely wasn't haunted that's
just what the neighbors think anyway
real lit continued of course they hadn't
sold the house they just left it when my
firm came in to repossess the place it
had all their belongings in it some
might even still be laying around here
anyway did you want to have a look at
that contract well strictly speaking
Milo was the only human living in his
new house he was never fully alone he
had arrived with his two closest friends
a pair of pets he had adopted while
living in his old house one was a
hamster by the name of donut named after
his round little body and the golden
brown shade of his fur had reminded Milo
of the glazed sugary baked treat the
other was Pixel a bearded dragon with a
pattern on his scales that resembled
some kind of mosaic art the first order
of business Milo had decided was before
even unpacking he needed to make sure
his scaly and furry friends each had a
suitable place to stay and that he got
them fed little did he realize there was
something else living in the house with
them something that was Far bigger and
was getting much hungrier than either of
his pets would looking around the house
Milo stumbled across a few boxes that he
hadn't brought with him like the
realator had said the shaw still had
some of their possessions left lying
around the place most of it was was
useless to Milo old man's clothes or a
set of knitting needles and rolls of
colorful thread it was those particular
clues that seemed to imply Mrs Shaw had
a lot of free time on her hands and
maybe took up knitting as a hobby during
retirement of course the bigger clue was
the huge handmade blanket that Milo
found draped over some of the remaining
boxes in the Attic he wasn't exactly
well versed in knitwear but he could
appreciate the craft behind this soft
blanket it clearly had a lot of time and
effort put into making it painstakingly
knitting each and every individual
thread looping it around a pair of Steel
needles and eventually after hours of
wearing out shaking bony fingers produce
something that actually looked quite
nice even though the idea of sitting and
knitting a blanket might have been one
of the most boring uses of time Milo
could imagine he still had to admit he
was surprised that the Shaws had left
this particular piece of bedding behind
it seemed like it would be pretty comfy
to sleep under and might help keep a
person warm at night now that the colder
seasons were approaching what's more was
that the blanket was clean almost like
it had been freshly washed there was no
old person smell on it no dirt or
discoloration not a stain and it hadn't
even accumulated any dust in its fibers
in fact he noticed that there was hardly
any dust at all up in the attic despite
the house being empty for so long he
assumed the realators had hired someone
As a caretaker while they found a buyer
for the place and they had kept the
place clean after all what other
conclusion could they have possibly
drawn it's not as if something had eaten
all the dust that would be absurd he'd
have a sort through of the Shaw's
leftovers later maybe sell some of it
off at a local yard sale or give it to a
thrift store but that blanket might come
in handy when it started snowing so Milo
had half a mind to keep it now part of
what makes moving home such a stressful
life experience isn't just all the
logistical and administrative parts of
the process it's only made worse by the
fact that it takes forever to move into
a new house fully that's the part
everyone always forgets about the months
after a move when you're forced to live
amongst towers of cardboard boxes all
your worldly possessions bu deep within
them and you can never remember which
crate anything is in when you urgently
need it so realizing it would take him
much longer to unpack all of his things
Milo set about making sure he had
everything that donut and pixel would
need already to hand the latter of his
two Pets the bearded dragon usually
spent most of his days in a spacious
glass tank Milo didn't love the idea of
keeping either of his two best buds so
confined but pixel never went very far
anyway content to lay under a heat lamp
almost perfectly still for most of the
day dut on the other hand was much more
of a free spirit the tiny brown hamster
physically could not stay still and most
days seemed to be filled with more
energy than Milo was as a result he let
the little guy roll about inside a
little plastic ball ball all day long
until his little hamster feet gave out
and now donut had much more space to zip
around inside his ball so while he
entertained himself Milo could focus on
what needed fixing cleaning and
generally improving around the house it
didn't take him long to realize however
that the Realtors had pulled a bit of a
fast one on him despite the absolute
steal of a price that Milo had been
offered it quickly became clear that the
unknown fate of the previous residence
wasn't the only detail about the house
that had been conveniently kept hidden
the place was in dire need of repair
with a lot of the old woodwork rapidly
rotting away if left unchecked parts of
the house could collapse and come apart
at the seams to make matters worse the
boiler was an ancient iron monstrosity
that was barely able to produce warm
water which would quickly become an even
bigger problem when the weather started
to get colder then to top off the
trifecta of unforeseen issues and
teething problems with his new place
Milo couldn't sleep it was to be
expected after all the house was old
worn out and had definitely seen better
days there were bound to be a few noises
the odd Creek coming from upstairs when
Milo and his two pets were all
downstairs the tapping of branches
against Windows blowing in the wind
outside but for some reason every
audible disturbance that emanated from
some hidden corner of the building only
seemed to get a thousand times louder
when the sun went down at nighttime
every squeaky floorboard or random noise
of the house settling was nearly
deafening enough to pull Milo right out
of what little Restless sleep he was
getting the worst part about it was
though he couldn't help it it made him
feel unwelcome as if Mr and Mrs Shaw
were angered that he had moved in in the
dark it was hard not to picture every
sound as one or both of the old couple
creeping through the corridors coming to
reclaim their home and remove Milo from
the premises one night the noises
started invading what little sleep Milo
did manage to get spilling into his
dream and causing them to devolve into
unsettling nightmares there was an old
photograph in a frame that he had come
across in the personal effects left
behind by the shaw showing the pair of
them staring disapprovingly out of the
image at him now thanks to the creaking
wooden structure of the house and the
sounds it made at night Milo was seeing
the old couple in every bad dream he had
both their faces were locked in those
same still frozen expressions of
contempt as they tried to exercise him
like an interlop on their property that
was the final nail in the coffin that
made Milo realize he needed to look at
other options surely there had to be
some way to induce a deep enough sleep
so that the sounds the house was making
weren't keeping him up or incepting
nightmares anymore he called the local
doctor arranging a consultation for
later that day as he hung up the phone
something nudged against his foot it was
donut having rolled through the Maze of
cardboard boxes still filling the house
Milo took one look at the little brown
fer hamster than the crates that still
littered the place grabbing the leftover
items that the shots had forgotten to
take with them before they vanished Milo
moved those boxes out into the shed he
knew he was probably reaching that it
was hard likely to make even the
slightest difference to his sleeping but
maybe keeping their stuff away from him
would keep the old couple out of his
head the only thing he kept in the house
was the blanket there was no use letting
it go to waste especially knowing that
the boiler was on the blink and it would
be cold soon he rolled it up and left it
on his bed leaving his more mobile pet
in the same room before heading out to
see the doctor when Milo got back a
bottle of prescription sleeping pills in
his pocket he couldn't help but notice
his room seemed different the blanket
looked like it had fallen off the bed
and onto the floor for one but more
worryingly Donut's plastic travel ball
had been split open laying in pieces on
the ground with its furly little
occupant nowhere to be seen over the
next few hours Milo searched every
corner of the house calling out to his
hamster trying to lure it back with more
morsels of food but donut didn't seem to
be anywhere he wasn't even underneath
the knitted blanket still there was no
sign as worry set in Milo hurly checked
pixel's cage to see if he was gone too
but the lizard was relaxing as lethargic
as ever completely unfazed by what was
going on it certainly seemed that when
it rained it really poured in this new
house just as he was searching for his
missing hamster Milo heard a new
horrible sound echo through the
corridors this one wasn't so much a
scary noise even if it did make him jump
but it was more the inconvenience that
came with it finally giving out after
God knows how many years it had been
installed for The house's boiler burst
spending the afternoon into the evening
failing to track down one of his Missing
Pets and stopping the huge ironcast
boiler from flooding the basement wasn't
exactly what Milo had in mind for fun
activities to do when he got hung home
going to bed frustrated made it as hard
to sleep as all the nightly cacophony of
creaking floorboards and branches raking
against the windows he tapped out two of
the pills the doctor had prescribed him
knocking them back with a sharp motion
of his head and a swig of cold water
before laying back in bed as night had
fallen the temperature also had
plummeted too and not having a boiler to
heat his room meant that Milo couldn't
stop himself from shivering in the cold
his breath forming clouds in front of
his face he he reached for the knitted
blanket and threw it over himself
curling up underneath it to try and
provide an extra layer of warmth to
protect himself from the gnawing cold
the pills did as they were meant to
helping Milo to quickly sleep into a
much deeper sleep than he had
experienced in a while although it
didn't seem to help the nightmares Mr
and Mrs Shaw came back again this time
they had Milo's arms and legs tied up
with their matching disapproving faces
the elderly couple threw something over
their helpless victim and tried to
smother him to death for a dream it felt
so intense so real Milo could feel a
heavy weight on top of his body as he
slept in fact it felt like it was all
around him engulfing and crushing the
life out of him from all sides but it
was the feeling of something wet against
his arm the sensation of liquid against
his skin and the numbness where his hand
should be were what finally pulled him
out of the dream and into the nightmare
through the dark and his cloudy vision
Milo could see a wide G gaping ma filled
with teeth the feeling of being crushed
was still surrounding him and despite
kicking his legs and trying to free
himself from confinement it didn't stop
squeezing him tighter his Panic was
already making it harder to catch his
breath but now he could barely feel his
lungs enough to scream for help not that
anyone was around to hear him but it was
the sight of his arm that chilled Milo's
blood it wasn't there anymore part of it
just above the elbow was just gone his
hand fingers every internal bone and
muscle had been reduced to a bloody mess
a slurry of red melting and coming apart
it was runny little more than a liquid
resembling the consistency of sand when
it's underwater and becomes sludge most
of his flesh was liquefied going further
up his arm and as the blanket pulled its
prey into its mouth until Milo was no
more not a trace of him left just like
the previous owners little did Milo or
the Shaws and donut before him know but
he'd been the victim of a creature that
was part of a rather unique species
while they will often vary in size shape
pattern and other aspects of their
appearance SCP 799 always seem to be
ordinary items of knitted bedwear at
least at first they retain heat like a
normal blanket wood and are soft to the
touch and for the most part don't seem
directly harmful and usually they aren't
SCP 799 are incapable of much movement
instead laying still a lot of time not
unlike a certain bearded dragon that
just lost its owner they also don't seem
to require much in the way of food
extracting what little nutrition they do
need by drawing in household dust a lot
of the organic matter in dust is
comprised of dead and discarded human
hair and skin cells so this makes sense
this feeding is all done through
filtered mouths in the fibers however
this changes if an SCP 799 blanket is
forced to go on a long time without food
will they possess this biological trait
themselves SCP 799 don't don't seem to
regard coldblooded animals to be the
source of food in fact they don't even
seem to be able to detect other
creatures with cold blood such as
reptiles instead SCP 799 will
metamorphose into a more predatory form
in order to consume any warm-blooded
mammal or human being it encounters
transforming its feeding orifices and
digestive tract into a singular mouth
lined with several rolls of sharp
pointed teeth from there it will wrap up
the largest warm-blooded animal it can
find whether that be a hamster or a
grown man and will tear off parts of its
prey reducing them to little more than a
thin slurry as it digests their body
mass to feed itself so if you move into
a new house and come across an old
knitted blanket maybe consider throwing
it out if you want to live high school
is a turbulent time for a lot of us to
say the least subjects are a lot harder
classes feel longer and because you're
older there can be so much more pressure
put on you by your teachers and parents
alike there's a lot more onus for you to
perform well in tests and make sure that
you get good grades thanks to everyone
around you telling you that these are
the most important years of your life or
that your high school experience will
determine your whole future for good or
for bad actually come to think of it
pressure feels like a bit of an
understatement as if there weren't
already enough things to worry about
when you're trying to make your way
through High School the changes to
yourself get thrown into the mix as well
growing up and getting older often means
developing a further previously unseen
level of self-awareness and
understanding of who you are as a person
that can be true of any part of life but
High School can often be the first time
we're aware of ourselves in such a
heightened way usually everything we're
experiencing during that time can make
some of us self-conscious shying away
from others to avoid embarrassment or
becoming Brash and loud to
overcompensate for just how uncertain
they might be feeling deep down then of
course on top of that already huge
mountain romantic feelings get thrown
into the mix as well sure in the grand
scheme of things High School romances
are usually just tiny almost
insignificant footnotes in the stories
of our lives but obviously they don't
feel like it at the time when you're
right there living through that part of
your life without the benefit of
hindsight that comes later your high
school Crush can feel like the very
center of the entire universe being
introduced to and surrounded by more
people than ever more than any previous
stage of schooling means that romantic
feelings usually have a higher
likelihood of developing and are made
more prominent by the whole other
Whirlwind of things that High School
brings with it case in point Ellie was
having this exact problem for as long as
she could remember she had never really
got people they were confused using
complicated and completely unpredictable
usually they frustrated Ellie which made
it hard for her to talk to most of her
classmates especially if she didn't
already know them that well the Common
Ground could sometimes make it a little
easier it helped break the ice but
finding those shared interests or
similarities was often harder than just
spending time on her own then came along
Marcus or Mary as Ellie heard he
preferred to be called on the first day
of the semester she had been placed in a
new math class the second Mary came
walking through the door she immediately
found herself unable to keep her eyes
off him especially because he ended up
taking the seat directly in front of
hers meaning he was always filling up
most of her view when she looks straight
ahead despite looking like a skater type
from what Ellie observed Mary was pretty
sharp she was no slouch herself usually
noting down correct answers a few
moments before whoever the teacher
called on whenever Mary was called on he
also had the exact right solution to
whatever problem or equation the rest of
the class was probably still struggling
to keep up with despite knowing very
little about him Ellie couldn't help
feeling a certain new and unfamiliar way
towards this particular classmate it was
like they were both operating at the
same speed on identical wavelengths if
only she knew more about him and it was
during class that Ellie had an idea
about how she could get to know him
better but without the awkward
uncomfortable interactions that came
from slipping about on the ice rather
than breaking it she could use the doll
sure she had been mulling it over toying
with the possibility for a while but
wasn't certain that it was right for her
to follow that course of action but as
the days turned into weeks getting
deeper and deeper into the semester
brought with it the possibility that
another girl would catch Mark's
attention the way he had caught Ellie
just the thought of that alone made her
want to cry she couldn't bear to see it
become reality one day in class her
chance presented itself on what had been
an unusually hot day the scorching heat
Outdoors was causing all the students to
groan in discomfort barely able to
acknowledge anything other than the high
temperature meanwhile all the teachers
could possibly do was open up the
windows to counteract the Relentless
weather but it was nothing more than a
futile gesture sitting down in front of
Ellie Mary Shrugged off the denim jacket
he always always wore leaving it to hang
over the back of his chair her eyes
honed in on what she needed clinging to
the surface of the acid washed material
was a single strand of black hair she
knew she had to pick her moment
carefully if the teacher or any of the
other students in the class or worst of
all Mary himself saw what she was doing
it would look beyond weird leaning
forward on her desk as subtly as she
could Ellie slowly reached forward her
fingers wouldn't reach the back back of
Mary's chair was just an inch or two
further than her arms extended Ellie
felt her heart stop for a split second
as her Crush moved in his chair the
shift causing the jacket to move and the
strand of his hair dropped almost
falling out of sight sighing with relief
as silently as she could when she saw
the black streak managed to stay
attached to the denim Ellie fished a pen
out from inside her pencil case leaning
forward again she delicately lifted the
pointed tip of her pen hooking the hair
on into it pulling it back towards her
before anyone saw she covered it with
her hand both to hide what she had done
and to stop the precious hair from being
caught by the warm humid Breeze pouring
through the open Windows gently she
placed the one missing component she
needed into a clean tissue which she
then folded four times and kept in her
jacket constantly checking throughout
the day to make sure it was still there
on more than one of those quick spot
checks Ellie felt her heart plummet
downwards for a second when she couldn't
immediately feel feel the tissue in her
pocket only to calm down a second later
to realize it was still there with its
precious contents inside too the rest of
the day she felt tense drumming her
fingers together in impatience every
hour feeling like it would go on forever
it was just a case of waiting out the
day until that final Bell rung the
moment she was able she rushed away from
the school walking home as quickly as
she possibly could one hand in her
pocket to keep keep the hair secure
Ellie was lucky enough or unlucky
depending on your view to live in the
same town as her school and not too far
away to need the bus she could make her
way there on foot in pretty decent time
normally the buses from the school would
pass her as she walked looking up she
saw one of the huge yellow Vehicles
driving down the street and a familiar
face sat at a window seat Marky seeing
him Ellie quickened her Pace speed
walking home the moment she unlocked the
front door door and closed it behind her
she threw off her backpack and raced
upstairs to her bedroom she knew exactly
where she'd left it as she flipped on
her lamp it was laying there on the desk
ready for her the naughty stalker the
tiny doll was made of one single knitted
string with a pair of shiny Onyx beads
against the red of its face in the place
of eyes Ellie had come across the little
odity in a box of her grandmother's
things although she never knew her all
that well after she had died Ellie's mom
had gone to clear her house up and came
back with a few boxes full of keepsakes
these are all your grandma's things I
couldn't sell or think of what to do
with her mother explained offering her
the cardboard box if you can pick out
anything that you like it's yours El I'm
sure Grandma wouldn't mind looking
inside there wasn't much save for a few
old clothes Snick knacks souvenirs and
trinkets that were mostly all broken or
the odd piece of jewelry that looked too
worn out and rusted to wear but right at
the bottom was the doll it was wrapped
up up in a crumpled piece of paper that
might have been clear white at some
point but i' changed shades with age
unfolding it Ellie read the message
inscribed on one side congratulations on
your purchase of a genuine naughty
stalker do you love someone but they
won't give you the time of day do you
wish you could hear what they say about
you behind their back well Wonder no
more using this fantabulous product you
can keep track of your loved ones every
move and their every word all you have
to do is get a single hair from the head
of the object of your desires slip it
under a loose string on our naughty
stalker and see what you're missing
another wonderful product brought to you
by the factory now that same crumpled
note was in Allie's hands her eyes
scanning over the instructions a final
time to make sure she knew exactly what
to do she didn't much care for the name
of it though naughty stalker the latter
word had a very negative connotation
what she was doing here wasn't stalking
Ellie told told herself she just wanted
an easier way to learn about Marky
surely there wouldn't be anything wrong
with that pulling the tissue from her
pocket she carefully lay it flat on the
desk and unfolded it the hair was still
there secured between the thin folded
paper delicately holding it between her
finger and thumb Ellie held the dark
strand of Mary's Hair in the light of
her desk lamp she treated it as gently
as she could making sure not to break
the hair worried that the doll might not
work if it snapped taking great care she
slipped it through one of the loops in
the naughty stalker string for a moment
nothing happened the doll just lay there
on the wooden surface of the desk it was
completely still not showing even the
slightest hint of any change feeling the
worry building more and more her heart
drumming against her chest so loud that
she could practically hear it Ellie
started frantically looking back over
the instructions in case she had somehow
missed a step she had no idea what was
meant to happen or even what she'd been
expecting but she was starting to think
that this doll might have just been an
odity from an old toy store that
marketed them to children by promising
things that weren't actually possible
see you later guys a tiny little voice
came from the desk causing Ellie's heart
to Lurch in shock the doll was standing
upright on the wooden surface only
seconds before it had been lying flat on
its back as if by its own accord the
little knitted figure was upright like
it was a living thing and it wasn't just
standing it's arm was waving and its
chest was even gently undulating to
mimic the motion of breathing the
naughty stalker kept waving a moment
only to drop its head forward and make
an exhaling motion that seemed to be a
sigh I really wish they wouldn't keep
calling me Marky the same voice spoke up
again this time more clearly coming from
the doll Ellie watched it closer
transfixed with utter Fascination she
was aware of the concept of a voodoo
doll a mystical charm that contained a
person's hair affixed to a crude figure
and in order to influence them through
magic this doll seemed much the same
except it was mimicking Marcus's every
move Ellie had overheard him talking to
some of his friends in the corridors at
school once talking about home he lived
in the next town over and the bus must
have only just arrived there because now
the doll was walking on the spot the
same heavy limed tired walk home after a
long strenuous day at school she
recognized the walk it was the same one
she did when she made her own way back
to her mom's house for the rest of the
night Ellie didn't take her eyes off the
naughty stalker watching as it streamed
marcus' actions to her live she watched
in real time as he arrived home sat and
did his homework and went back
downstairs to eat dinner all the while
Ellie was neglecting to do those same
things herself at one point in the night
the doll started dancing around singing
into something invisible in its hand it
made Ellie smile uncontrollably to watch
she had figured out that Marcus was now
playing playing some music through a
pair of headphones or a speaker and
singing along in a hairbrush dancing
like no one was watching the kind of
thing that almost everyone does when
they're alone but never admits to
turning to her computer keeping one eye
on the doll refusing to stopped watching
it even in her peripheral vision Ellie
typed the lyrics it was singing into a
search engine immediately Pages worth of
results came up for the song and the
band that had sung it they weren't a
group that she had heard of or listened
to before but but it was Friday she had
all weekend using her mom's card Ellie
ordered herself a t-shirt with the
band's name on it premium delivery meant
it would be there before school next
week on Monday she showed up at the
school wearing the new shirt it was a
few sizes too big but that meant that
the band's logo printed on the front was
bigger and harder to Miss Ellie had
spent almost her whole weekend watching
the doll as it mimicked Marcus's
movements he hadn't done much but play
video games and go to the skate park but
she made sure she knew what he was doing
doing anytime she wasn't watching she
was listening to the music he liked
getting familiar with it to prepare
herself for what was about to happen as
if she had been studying to get ready
for a test somehow striding through the
corridors full of students Milling about
first thing in the morning Ellie felt
more confident than ever hey Marcus She
greeted spotting her Crush rumaging
around in his locker and walking
straight up to him hey uh he paused
looking over her for what felt like like
the first time you you're um sorry we
have class together right math yeah she
replied surprising herself at how
quickly she'd recovered from the blow
that he didn't even know her name I'm
Ellie I sit right behind you right right
Marcus smiled you don't have to use my
full name everyone just calls me Mary
around here but you don't like that
nickname I can tell Ellie shot him a
smile trying to do her best mysterious
voice how how can you tell yeah asked
don't tell anyone she leaned forward and
whispered but I'm kind of psychic they
both laugh and Ellie caught Marcus's eye
reading the band name on her shirt hey I
had no idea that you were a parallel
lunatics fan he remarked that's my
favorite band well I just started
listening to them Ellie replied maybe
you could recommend me some more of
their albums suddenly the school bell
sounded interrupting their conversation
with a reminder that the day had to
start waving goodbye and heading to
class Ellie was unable to stop herself
from smiling now that her way in had
worked for the rest of the week she kept
relying on the doll every moment she
wasn't in class she was holding it to
her ear listening to Marcus's half of
every conversation the more she did the
more she learned about him what music he
liked where he was thinking of going to
college and what he wanted to study
there every time she passed him in the
hallway she'd give him a smile and wave
just to remind him that she was there it
was a long game but she hoped it would
end in the way she wanted 9 days had
passed and she started using the doll
and that's when it started to become
somewhat unreliable over the weekend it
had been moving as though Marcus was at
the skate park again but when Ellie
approached him to ask how his weekend
was and if he'd enjoyed going skating he
looked at her with confusion Marcus said
he'd been visiting his dad that weekend
and didn't have any time to go anywhere
near the skate park but that one
inaccuracy was nothing compared to what
she heard the doll say next still using
it to listen in on marcus' conversations
the na stalker had started relaying
words that made her heart shatter into a
thousand fragments she overheard him
talking to a friend about her saying
horrible things like how he thought she
was weird and that she had clearly
listened to parallel lunatics just to
get his attention worst of all was when
Ellie heard Marcus say through the doll
that he would never want to date a girl
like her she was heartbroken tears
streaming down her face as she hid in
the toilet cubicle during lunch break
sniff shling wiping her eyes in her
baggy band t-shirt Ellie felt her
sadness turning into a wave of rising
anger throwing the door open she marched
out of the bathroom and started
searching the school for Marcus how
could you say those things about me she
yelled furiously when she found him
sitting on the window ledge halfway up a
stairwell huh he mumbled lifting up his
headphones instantly noticing that she
seemed upset hey Ellie are you okay
you're a jerk she screamed almost
choking on sobs that threatened to come
bursting out in a flood of Tears why
were you saying horrible stuff about me
what are you talking about Marcus asked
his face looking utterly confused don't
play dumb you said I thought I was weird
and that you never date someone like me
whoa Ellie I don't know who told you
that but that's not true I mean I don't
know you all that well but I never say
anything like he tried to reply liar she
cut him off with another yell I heard
you I was listening to every word what
do you mean you were listening the
confusion on marcus' face quickly turned
to concern concern in his mind he was
quickly putting two and two together the
band shirt the question about the skate
park have you been following me
instantly Ellie felt her stomach flip
her anger partially dissipating and
replaced with fear no no it's not like
that she said trying to ease his look of
obvious alarm I I just wanted to know
more about you and now I do what the
hell does that mean Marcus asked
sounding almost frightened I I know
everything about you Ellie started
stepping closer thinking if she went in
for a hug that might calm them both down
I know all your favorite music what you
like to do for fun I wanted to know
because I really like you but I didn't
know how to talk to you s stay away from
me instinctively marcus' arm reacting to
her getting too close pushed Ellie
backwards behind her was nothing but a
sharp drop in a flight of concrete steps
with a scream she tumbled backward her
body barreling down the stairs until her
head hit the ground at the bottom of the
last stair giving a sickening crack as
her neck broke teachers could barely
hold back the students that came
crowding out trying to get a better look
as the paramedics came to take Ellie
away as they lifted her body onto a
stretcher nobody noticed something fall
out of her pocket an unused naughty
stalker doll a brand new instance ofp
693 Joe sighed to himself quietly
looking out of the window at the still
silent stretch of highway snaking
through the desert only to disappear
Somewhere Over the Horizon the sun was
slowly crawling down almost completely
vanished from sight and he knew when it
was gone there'd be no light left in the
desert it wasn't the same kind of
Darkness you found in a city there they
had street lights and cars whizzing
through with their headlights on full
blast it never really got dark in the
cities but out here nothing but true
pitch black darkness for miles around
only alleviated when the sky was clear
enough for the stars to shine through or
broken by the beams of a passing car
speeding down the highway giving another
sigh Joe sipped on his coffee by this
point it was lukewarm to match the
dropping temperature outside and bitter
to The Taste but he needed the caffeine
to keep himself awake after all he had a
long night ahead of him but then again
they were all long nights in this line
of work this was the only Diner from
miles around and he had no idea just how
many hours it would be before he next
got to eat or drink anything with an
almost empty podt with the last drags of
coffee in one hand the waitress came up
to Joe at his table it was the last spot
in the diner with anyone still sitting
in it closing time she told him with a
tired smile one for the road nodding Joe
lifted his travel mug for her to fill as
her workday was ending his was about to
start he grabbed his jacket and slung it
over his shoulder leaving a few dollars
as a tip on the table before he made his
way out of the diner and over to his car
buckling into the driver's seat Joe took
a deep breath as he pulled his phone out
of his pocket dreading the potential
barrage of notifications that would come
flooding through the second he did
opening up the corresponding app he
clocked in for the night and sure enough
was instantly met with a veritable Title
Wave of requests grumbling quietly to
himself he tapped accept on the first
one he saw and turned the key in the
ignition working as a driver for a car
poool and ride sharing service was far
from a simple job at the best of times
but even more in this particular area of
the southwestern United States the state
of New Mexico shared a border not only
with Texas but with Chihuahua one of the
northernmost states of Mexico being so
close to the Border meant that most of
the calls and requests for lifts that
Joe received on an average night meant
he needed to bounce back and forth
between the US and Mexico crossing the
border at his clients were Quest legally
of course we're not going all Breaking
Bad here today some Knights weren't so
so complicated someone might just need a
quick ride from donana to the town of
Truth or Consequences a New Mexico town
named after we kid you not a TV game
show sure that might have been a 75m
drive up the I25 but at least it didn't
involve Crossing from El Paso into the
city of Warz at this time of night it
was nowhere near as busy as during the
day but even so that didn't make hopping
back and forth over the border and all
the red tape it entailed any less of an
arduous process especially stuck behind
the wheel of a car for hours on end
tonight however wasn't a simple night
Joe's first call was for a pickup from a
couple whose flight had been rerouted to
the international airport in Warz they
seemed to be Newly Weds and demanded to
be taken all the way back to a hotel in
Las Cruses making it abundantly clear
that they didn't want to stay closer to
the airport and outright refusing when
Joe offered to recommend them some
nearby hotels getting to know most of
the area around the three-way
intersection between New Mexico Texas
and the Mexican border after driving
around it so many times he'd gotten to
know the area pretty well unfortunately
not everyone wanted to hear a display of
Joe's local knowledge most of them just
wanted him to drive them in silence next
up a group of Rowdy guys real frat house
types from the university of El Paso
Texas they wanted to be taken to a bar
halfway across the city a bit more of a
straightforward trip Joe thought
although he could have done without them
drunkenly chanting spring break at the
top of their lungs every 5 minutes after
that it was another ja across the border
this time transporting a suit and
Stenson wearing Texas gentleman to
Horizon City he spent the whole ride on
his phone talking at length about a
business deal he just closed not saying
a word to Joe the entire time Doug
Dimmadome eat your heart out the next
person to request a lift wasn't much
more talkative either she was a 20-some
girl who plainly stated she just wanted
to get far away from a Blanca hours and
hours had ticked by since Joe had left
the diner the last of the coffee and his
travel mug have been finished long
before his next ride request had come
through and required him to once again
make the drive out to the other side of
the Border by this point the evening had
turned into night and was now
approaching the earliest hours of the
following morning the desert still
filled with nothing but deep Inky Pless
the same desert that had scorched Acres
upon Acres of skin that had taken so
many lines knes big and small and had
picked the skin and flesh from countless
Bones the desert can be a truly
merciless place at the best of times but
sometimes there's a little something
more out there just waiting for you dark
and hungry occasionally as he drove back
towards El Paso Joe would see another
car speeding towards him on the other
side of the highway but it was so dark
that he could see nothing of the driver
only their headlights were visible right
up until they drove past him everything
behind the hood of the oncoming car
almost imperceptible as it whiz through
the night crossing the border so many
times a night Joe had become friendly
with a few of the officers that
patrolled the gates waving cars pass
after they'd shown the necessary
paperwork he was never usually held
there for long enough to start actual
conversations with them exchanging only
a friendly nod or oneliner with the few
border patrol guards whose names he
could still remember but sometimes when
things were a little quieter at the
gates he'd overhear the odd passing
comment while his driver side window was
rolled down tonight as the long barrier
in front of his car was raised Joe
caught a few words coming through on a
radio belonging to one of the guards
something vague about sightings of
phantom lights he chuckled to himself
writing it off as yet another alleged
alien sighting something about the
desert at night really seemed to capture
people's imaginations Joe thought to
himself as he pulled away from the
border gate heading for the I 10 there
were always stories like that
circulating around this area of New
Mexico it was easy to see why being so
close to Roswell New Mexico the home of
alien sightings and just a couple
hundred miles away from the true alien
Mecca Area 51 a United States Air Force
Base that secretly housed alien life
forms and spaceships allegedly at least
if years of conspiracy Believers and
Facebook memers are to be believed every
so often one of Joe's passengers would
ask him about unidentified flying
objects or he'd overhear them talking
amongst themselves about a slew of urban
legends Phantom hitchhikers that would
hitch rides on the highway only to
vanish from the back seats of cars and
of course Tales of disembodied floating
lights either hovering way up in the sky
or just above the ground regardless of
whichever one was popular at any given
moment Joe knew there were plenty of
weird and spooky stories coming out of
the desert what he was unaware of
however was that he was currently in one
of his own he'd been so wrapped up in
thoughts of what he might do if one of
the people that hired him turned out to
be a Wandering spirit that Joe didn't
even notice he had made a wrong turn it
was only by the virtue of glancing at
his car's GPS that he even realized and
by then it had been long enough since
that he was completely Unsure how far
back it was that he had made such an
error according to the map he was
nowhere he hadn't stopped his car was
still moving at a steady speed down the
long stretch of asphalt but the GPS
didn't show any road at his current
location he had no clue which part of
which Highway he was even on short on
options and short on time to get to his
next client for the night Joe just did
what his job required of him he kept on
driving anyone watching from a distance
would have seen an empty lengthly
portion of Highway with but one single
car traveling along it only the
headlights both Illuminating the road in
front of it and giving away the car's
position slowing down slightly just to
play it safe Joe tried searching up
where he was using the maps app on his
phone he figured he wouldn't get stopped
for checking his phone while driving
driving or be much risk to any other
drivers on the road after all it seemed
like his was the only car around for
Miles even if he was still heading in
near enough the right direction for his
next pickup that would be at least some
Saving Grace maybe the map on the cars
built in GPS was a little outdated he
thought and that was preventing this
part of the highway from showing up
connection to the internet was extremely
limited this far out in the New Mexico
Desert and by the time the map loaded it
didn't provide much in the way of new
information or even even the slightest
bit of comforting reassurance it only
seemed to agree with the GPS that Joe
was well and truly lost as he took his
free hand off the wheel for a split
second just to try and zoom in on the
satellite view of the terrain two bright
white lights appeared in the distance
startled Joe dropped his phone into the
front passenger seat hearing it slip
onto the floor of the car as he gripped
the steering wheel again both hands back
to 10 and two the lights were speeding
in the opposite direction he was driving
in a fair few ft ahead of him but still
it was another vehicle on this otherwise
empty isolated stretch of the highway a
loud and sudden idea rang out in Joe's
head if he could signal what he had
assumed to be another approaching car he
could ask the driver where exactly he
was and what the quickest route to get
back to the I 10 was he couldn't
guarantee he would make the oncoming
vehicle stop and help him after all so
few people would willingly trust a
stranger on the highway but considering
his only other options were to either
keep driving along the seemingly endless
Road or to turn back around and try to
find wherever it was he'd made the wrong
turn in the first place needless to say
Joe's hands were a little tied tapping
the appropriate switch a fix to his
wheel he flicked on his own headlights
on and off in an effort to catch the
other driver's attention nothing the
pair of headlights kept their current
course both theirs and Joe's traveling
parallel to each other as if they were
about to joust with their beams of light
hitting the switch again Joe tried
lowering his headlight setting and then
raising them back to full brightness
still nothing from the other driver he
pushed the emergency button that
activated both the front and rear lights
of the car but this one only yielded the
same result deciding there was nothing
else that he could do Joe gently pulled
his vehicle over parking abruptly at
this side of the highway he
instinctively checked his rear view only
to remember that there wasn't anyone
behind him just him and the Apparently
oblivious driver approaching ahead in a
last ditch effort to get their attention
Joe punched the car horn rolling down
his window in order to listen for a
response the blaring noise echoed
through the empty desert night a loud
and sustained blast followed by a beat
of silence as Joe paused waiting to hear
the same sound back from the oncoming
vehicle he squinted at it through the
dark it was still pretty far but closing
rapidly or as far as he could tell it
was all he had to go on was the
advancing lights with nothing visible
behind them Joe leaned out of his window
hoping that it would somehow give him
better visibility through the sheer
darkness of a desert at night it did as
little to improve things as a second
much longer blast of his horn did the
other driver still didn't react by now
the lights were close enough that
whoever was behind the other wheel would
be able to see Joe and yet they didn't
do anything to change their speed didn't
flicker their lights back or sound their
own horn nothing just the same two
points of light they might as well have
been floating just above the ground
given how they obscured what was behind
them at this point Joe was certain they
were close enough to see him now little
more than a few feet in front of his
stationary car and still closing at a
sustained speed getting agitated he went
to hit his horn a third time when he
noticed something or rather he noticed
something that he hadn't this car
hurling towards him through the night
wasn't making any sound it wasn't just
that the other driver deliberately
hadn't returned the signals Joe had been
trying to give there was no noise coming
from it whatsoever no grumbling of an
engine nor the rolling of rubber tires
against the asphalt surface of the the
highway it was silent just the pair of
ominous lights soundlessly racing
through the night heading straight for
where Joe was sat parked still a Sitting
Duck like he was defenseless prey
violently turning the key in the
ignition Joe slammed his foot down on
the accelerator his car sputtered to
life and Ken down the road he was headed
straight for the other car if it even
was a car hoping to shoot straight past
it and take his chances continuing along
the highway alone the lights were almost
on top of him now still too bright to
make out anything behind them but there
was still no engine noise nothing to
indicate what the hell it even was until
one of them jumped onto the hood of his
car an orb of light attached to a
thrashing shape beneath parted from the
other it leaped through the air and came
down right in the path of Joe's Car just
as he was about to pass what he first
thought to be another car the light
smashed directly through the windshield
Joe instinctively lifting an arm to
cover his face and protect his eyes from
the impending shower of broken glass but
it was in that second that he took his
eyes off the road that the other light
made its move it had been perfectly
parallel with Joe's Car only to turn
sharply and violently connecting with
the driver's side door with enough Force
to not only Dent the metal surface but
to completely lift the car up it
barreled sideways tumbling over itself
off the highway and into the surrounding
desert trapped inside buckled tight Joe
was thrown about in his seat unable to
study himself as the car rolled his arm
was still over his face splinters of
glass showering over him the whatever it
was was still thrashing about its glow
Illuminating the entire interior of the
car until the whole vehicle came to a
stop Landing upside down wheels in the
air pointing up at the Cloudy night sky
hanging the wrong way up Joe reached for
his seat belt and unclasped it his head
instantly dropped onto the ceiling of
the upturn car through the shattered
driver side window he crawled out on his
hands the pain was shooting through his
whole body bruises and blood covering
his arms and an intense agonizing
feeling of broken bones on top of that
rolling over onto his back Joe looked up
at the wreck of his car his livelihood
and the monster standing in front of it
illuminated fully for the first time by
the car's still active headlights the
thing had managed to pull itself free
from the destroyed windshield and was
now pacing slowly around the overturned
Hood it walked on two legs but it didn't
move like a man in fact it didn't even
look like one it was like something
pulled straight out of prehistoric times
a pair of Hing limb supporting a
streamlined reptilian body with hooked
claws on its feet its back was arched
keeping itself low as its two arms
stayed close to its Center the creature
had almost humanlike hands but each
finger was tipped with long pointed
Talons but its head was what Joe saw
first what he had seen at a distance and
mistaken for car headlights only a few
minutes ago in the place he wouldn't
have expected to see a pair of slitted
eyes staring at him was a bulbous mass
of a head bioluminescent light glowed
from beneath the monster's skin a brain
visible amongst a web of bright organs
and beneath that a wide gaping maw of
sharp teeth Joe noticed another light
Drawing Near brightening the area where
he lay defenseless the second of the
raptor-like monsters was pacing closer
to him both their glowing heads kept low
to the ground ready to
strike Yep looks pretty clear to me one
of the men disguised as a highway patrol
officer announced and BR mad chob with
what their front paws look like no trace
of the driver just a big wreck in the
middle of nowhere H better get on the
horn to control then his colleague
replied wearing a similar uniform I
thought SCP 745s are only found a little
north of here ah we shut off the section
of the highway they usually show up at
the First Foundation agent explained
casually sipping his coffee as he looked
at the upturn wreckage of Joe's Car his
body was nowhere to be found but every
now and then a couple of them will show
up a bit away from there one of them
wouldn't come this far into the south of
New Mexico on its own though ah because
of the lights right his fellow agent
responded the two of them walking back
towards the car yeah they're heads they
mimic car headlights or something well
there's that the first man nodded taking
one less look at the long open desert
around them and the highway stretching
through it blastard musk get lonely
traveling out here on your own an
elderly woman watches from her living
room window as heavy Sheets of Rain Fall
outside she rocks back and forth in her
chair nervously it's been raining for
days the road is washed out I can't get
into town oh what am I to do what am I
to do she says out loud to herself the
rocking chair Creeks under her weight
but not as much as it had 3 days ago
before she ran out of food I am so
hungry the old lady moans she glances at
the door that leads to her basement
maybe I can find something to eat down
there she stands up her 90-year-old
bones Creek as she slowly shuffles
towards the basement door the empty
chair rocks back and forth from the old
woman's momentum as if someone is still
sitting in it she opens the door and
looks into the pitch black darkness
there are no windows down there the only
light is connected to a drawring in the
middle of the room the old woman slowly
makes her way down the uneven wooden
steps when she reaches the bottom she
reaches out her wrinkled hand groping in
the Darkness for the drawstring her hand
brushes something it feels like sticky
yarn then she feels the legs of a spider
Scurry up her arm the old woman lets out
a shriek as her hand locates the string
and she pulls hard the light flickers on
it creates a dim glow but at least she
can now see what's in the basement the
string swings back and forth casting a
snake-like shadow on the far wall the
old woman scans the floor for anything
to eat a leftover tunic can some pickled
vegetables a rat anything will do at
this point there is nothing there the
old woman feels her strength has been
almost completely drained she doesn't
know how she'll make it back up the
stairs in desperation she looks around
the basement One Last Time her eyes fall
on an old rusty saw she pauses for a
moment I need to eat she Whispers The
Old Woman slowly walks towards the saw
she picks it up and examines it God gave
me two hands for a reason she says her
eyes locked on the rusty blade she
places one hand on the wooden workbench
that sits against the wall and grips the
saw tightly with the other the old woman
takes a deep breath and brings the saw
down towards her hand where are we going
d94 322 asks the SCP agent driving the
car house on Hayley Hill the agent
responds well that doesn't sound creepy
at all d94 322 says as he cranes his
neck to get a glimpse of the top of the
mountain through the SUV window why
don't we just play the the quiet game
until we get there the agent says as he
focuses on the pothole ridden back roads
of Mount Zion Georgia d94 322 holds on
tightly to the handhold above him to
keep his body from slamming into the
door every time they go over a big bump
they continue on for a few more minutes
when a rundown house comes into view the
agent pulls off the road and stops the
SUV here you go he says handing d94 322
an earpiece what am I supposed to do
with this D9 4322 asks just stick it in
your ear the agent says with just a
little contempt in his voice you don't
have to be rude about it d94 322 replies
as he grabs the earbud and sticks it in
his ear hello testing anybody out there
hello d94 322 can you hear me says a
voice in his head uh yeah you can just
call me d94 for short d94 322 is kind of
a mouthful very well the voice from the
earbud agrees my name my name is Dr
Andrews I will be walking you through
this test with SCP
4173 all right doc shall we get this
party started d94 says as he steps out
of the SUV he looks up at the house that
sits a top Hadley Hill the sky is dark
and clouds race over the mountain as if
they would rather be anywhere else but
here here we go d94 starts walking up
the slippery Hill being careful not to
fall he reaches the overgrown walkway
leading up to the house and pauses is
there a problem Dr Andrew asks no just
trying to psych myself up to go into
this creepy house responds d94 what's
inside anyways that is not your concern
at the moment but if you do exactly as I
tell you you should be in and out in no
time whatever you say Doc d94 walks down
the path reaches his hand out and grips
the cool brass knob he turns it and
pushes the door open the inside of the
house smells like moth balls and decay
all right I'm in he says good head down
the hallway and turn to your left you'll
see a door that leads to the basement
let me know when you're there d94 walks
down the hallway the old wooden floor
groans under his feet he reaches the
basement door it's slightly a jar this
place gives me the creeps rightfully so
Dr Andrews chimes in it is an old spooky
house on top of an old spooky Hill in
the middle of nowhere obvious viously
it's going to be creepy an old woman
died here under mysterious circumstances
around 20 years ago but you don't really
need to worry about that no ghosts here
I think you think d94 shouts as he takes
a step away from the basement
door I'm just kidding there's nothing
but harmless old SCP 4173 in that house
and when as an SCP ever heard anyone
right there is a long uncomfortable
pause any anyways why don't you head on
downstairs so we can get you out of
there as soon as possible yeah sure d94
says as he begins his descent into the
darkness I can't see anything is there a
light no I think it burnt out years ago
but that's okay I can guide you it's
what I'm here for says Dr Andrews walk
towards the East wall but watch your
head the ceiling is low in that corner
you'll see what you're looking for when
you get there d94 is silent for a moment
East he asks turn left Dr Andrews
responds oh all right why didn't you say
so doc d94 turns left and walks forward
after a few feet there's a loud bang as
he slams his head into the ceiling son
of a I told you to watch your head
yeah thanks says d94 as he rubs the bump
forming beneath his hair this place is
even spookier than the first floor you
know that right I promise there is
nothing in that room right now that can
hurt you Dr Andrews reassures d94 wait
what do you mean right now don't worry
about it just let me know when you reach
the wall d94 after a few seconds D 94's
eyes adjust to the darkness he can just
make out the damp concrete wall in front
of him it looks as if the wall is
perspiring I'm here he says good there's
a little door maybe 5 ft to your left
you see it asks Dr Andrews d94 turns
yeah I I see it it's closed the door in
is not very big maybe a foot long and a
half a foot wide open it says Dr Andrew
d94 hesitates what what's in there
nothing just open it Dr Andrews repeats
himself no way man you're lying and I'm
not opening anything until you tell me
what's on the other side of that door Dr
Andrew sigh we both know that you're
going to do as I say d94 322 you have no
other choice unless you want to go back
to that death row cell block where we
found you
d94 shakes his head and rubs the bridge
of his nose
fine fine he says Dr Andrews can hear
the squeaking of hinges through the
microphone on d94s earbud it's open now
what do you see anything uh no there's
some cobwebs and dirt but other than
that it's just dark d94 thinks for a
moment why is this little door here is
this some like pet door or something you
have to be I don't know pretty small to
get in there agreed just hang tight and
let me know when you hear something we
won't keep you there for long hear
something like like what asks d94 you'll
know when you hear it says Dr Andrews 5
minutes go by without a sound then 10 15
the basement is damp and cold d94 thinks
he sees creatures scurrying around the
floor but he doesn't say anything
because acknowledging them makes his
situation more real and a lot more scary
after a half hour of waiting in silence
din d94 screams what the heck was that
what was what Dr Andrews is startled out
of a Daydream by the shouts of d94 in
his ear something just moved past the
door I definitely saw it what in God's
name was that yells d94 Dr Andrews tries
to remain calm but he can barely contain
his excitement the entity in the wall is
why you're down there what do you mean
you said there wasn't anything down here
I said there was nothing down there that
could hurt you if you follow my
instructions this will continue to be
true can you hear it anything asks Dr
Andrews no I can't hear it but before
d94 can finish his sentence a voice
speaks from behind the wall he can't
understand what the voice is saying at
first but as his heart begins to slow
and the blood stops thumping in his ears
d94 can make out her words oh thank
goodness I wasn't sure you'd be able to
find me what took you so long says the
voice of an old woman d94 takes a step
back from the door there's someone on
the other side of that wall he hisses
into the microphone at Dr Andrews tell
it that the road is out and you had to
find another way up says Dr Andrews in
d94 is earpiece what why just do it if
you want to get out of there d94 Dr
Andrew says a little impatiently uh the
the road is out so I had to find another
way up says d94 to the little Open Door
in the wall oh yes the rainwashed it out
I was worried I wouldn't ever get to see
another person again being stuck up here
and all can you see me asks the voice um
no I I can't says d94 do what is on the
other side of that wall come over here a
little closer I I can't see you properly
either says the voice it's fine you can
get closer just don't touch the door Dr
Andrews says I really don't want to do
that says d94 do it and you'll be that
much closer to getting out I hate you
Whispers D9 for he slowly approaches The
Little Door and speaks into it hello oh
there you are the voice pauses as if
whoever speaking is examining d94 I'm
sorry I can't see like I used to it's so
dark in here and it's been so long reach
through the door and let me feel your
hand so I can tell you're really there
what d94 steps away from the door no way
am I putting my hand in there come on
now don't be rude I just want to feel
that you're there it's been so long just
just a touch the voice says a little
harsher than before screw you lady I'm
not getting my hands anywhere near This
creepy hole in the wall says d94 he
turns around and starts walking away
from The Little Door towards the
staircase leading back to the main level
of the house before he can put his foot
on the first step d94 hears Dr Andrew's
voice screaming in his ear stop moving
look you're going to have to do it we
haven't been able to recover anyone who
refuses to do what she asks I cannot
guarantee your safety unless you put
your hand through that door are you
kidding me shouts d94 you're telling me
that sweet creepy old lady will somehow
kill me if I don't do what she asks
we're not entirely sure what happens but
you need to put your hand through that
door if you want to get out of there
says Dr Andrews d94 turns back toward
the little door and slowly approaches it
this is my nightmare he says more to
himself than anyone else he reaches out
slowly and puts his fingers through the
doorway he immediately pulls them back
and steps away from the door I I I
really don't want to do this d94
Whispers he steps forward again and
sticks his hand all the way through the
doorway for a moment nothing happens all
right I've got my hand in there now what
oh I can see you now you're right there
thank you for coming oh it's been so
long since someone came and with a gift
as well oh sweetling you're so kind so
kind to me me G gift what gift d94 asks
nervously it's so dark and Lonesome and
I've just been so hungry for such a long
time thank you sweetling I'll take your
gift from you you are such a rude little
brat you don't really deserve it you've
had it for too long and you don't
deserve it it's mine now mine for my
belly thank you what are you talking
about you psycho d94 stutters suddenly
something grabs his hand and pulls him
against the wall he screams in agony as
Dr Andrews hears a wet ripping sound
coming through the microphone it sounds
as if some type of metal instrument is
cutting through flesh oh God no help me
help me d94 screams please please please
Dr Andrews hears the sound of d94s body
hitting the floor as he passes out it's
quiet for a moment don't worry you
ungrateful child don't worry I'll fill
you up too you can have mine I'll give
it to you sweet boy good boy fill you up
says the old woman's voice from the
other side of the wall Dr Andrews
listens as the hinges of The Little Door
squeak and it clicks shut he picks up
the phone next to him and dos it go in
and get him bring him back to site 94
for observation and try to keep this one
alive please he hangs up the phone and
prepares the lab for d94 322 to be
brought in d94 slowly comes out of his
medically induced coma 2 days after the
incident with SCP
4173 he's stable but doesn't feel great
and he can't help but sense that
something is different d94 looks at
where his hand should be there's nothing
there that crazy old lady ate my hand he
starts screaming a medical team rushes
in as red lights begin to flash and
Sirens blare they attempt to restrain
d94 during the struggle d94 catches a
glimpse of himself in a mirror on the
far side of the room he stops fighting
for a moment there was a growth
expanding from his head what the heck is
that he yells pointing to his reflection
d94 begins to struggle again this time
much more intensely he begins scratching
at the growth on the side of his head
without much success in the process he
pushes the growth further into his skull
it penetrates his brain d94 blacks out
the medical team ties d94 to the bed and
tries to get a reading on his vitals the
growth is putting too much pressure on
his brain they Rush him to the ER but
d94 322 dies before he reaches the
operating table Dr Andrew stands over
the body of the deceased class D subject
cut him open he says to the doctors
standing in the room one of them pulls
out a scalpel and makes an incision into
the side of d94 head what is that one of
the doctors says the other bends over to
get a better look after a moment he
turns away and vomits into his face mask
Dr Andrews picks up a pair of forceps
off the table he sticks them deep into
the hole in the side of d94 head and
clamps down hard Dr Andrews pulls out a
decomposing hand the fingers are still
moving as if trying to grab onto
something there is no explanation for
how it got in there but it is obvious
that SCP 4173 played some sort of role
in the phenomenon Dr Andrews goes back
into his office to review previous Case
Files on SCP
4173 everyone who had put their hand
into the small doorway has been pulled
towards the wall and had their hand
chopped off the severed appendage never
ends up being a clean cut which leads Dr
Andrews to hypothesize the gruesome
makeshift operation is done with some
sort of tool with teeth once the hand of
the victim is severed SCP 4173 always
thanks the person for their gift she
then informs them not to worry about
their hand as it will be replaced but
then something incredibly strange
happens like with d94 a decaying hand
will appear somewhere in the body but it
isn't always inside the head in fact
depending on how polite the test subject
is to the old woman behind the door the
closer to the wrist the decaying hand
actually ends up for the test subjects
who are rude to the old lady the
decaying hand ends up in some pretty
interesting places she really hated d94
322 Chuckles Dr Andrews to himself Dr
Andrews continues flipping to the back
of the file on SCP
4173 the SCP Foundation doesn't quite
know how it happens but people who
refuseed to offer their hand to SCP 4173
suffer a worse fate than those who
surrender to the old lady in every case
where a subject tries to get away from
the small door some inexplicable Force
seems to grab them from behind and drag
them through the tiny opening in these
cases there is nothing left of the test
subject it is likely fatal as a human is
much smaller than the opening itself so
the only way a body could fit through
the doorway is if every bone is broken
and every muscle compressed to a quarter
of its actual ual size I'm not sure
which is worse Dr Andrews says aloud as
he closes the file on SCP
4173 he glances at the picture paper
clip to the front of the manila folder
depicting the tiny doorway he can't
quite pinpoint why but the fact that the
door slowly closes after the old woman
gets what she needs from her victims
sends chills down his spine the words of
the old woman echo in his head don't
worry I'll fill you up too you can have
of mine I'll give it to you sweet boy
good boy fill you up gamma would never
forget the horrific sight of SCP
5967 on the surface she kept her nerve
cool and collected her finger ready to
squeeze the trigger as her weapon stayed
trained on the entity but deep down it
turned her stomach after all how is
someone meant to react when they see a
thing like that a mess of Flesh and
eyeballs towering above them staring
back through more retinas than any
living creature has she did not yet know
it but she'd still be seeing that
disgusting pillar of musculature and
eyes in her nightmares for months to
come and still it wasn't even the worst
part of the incursion far worse than
seeing the 5 m tall eyeball totem
watching it blink its many Lids at her
was witnessing what it had done to Alpha
only moments before gamma's commanding
officer had been in control of this
situation leading mobile task force
Lambda 5 into the Meadowlands of East
Rutherford New Jersey the mission should
have been a simple Smash and grab the
same old boring story their team had
lived through countless times before
pick up a high value Target the leader
of yet another cult practicing an
anomalous religion and bring him in for
questioning gamma never could have
expected that things would go this badly
the the task force had arrived to
discover Caesar Winters the leader of a
sect of fifths operating in New Jersey
when Lambda 5 discovered him Winters and
his followers locals who were all
members of a group known as the commune
were standing in a circle around an
instance of SCP
5967 standing at around 5 m in height
SCP 5967 were piles comprised of mostly
musculature and organs that resembled
eyeballs human eyeballs despite lacking
a mouth vocal cords or any other
conventional methods of speech these
pillars could still very much
communicate verbally although they had
little to say besides spouting phrases
and principles associated with the
fifthist ideology almost immediately the
plan to capture Winters had gone aai it
was almost like he expected the
foundation to arrive like he knew they
were coming as the members of MTF Lambda
5 moved in and keeping Winters in their
sights the anomalous cult leader somehow
turned the Gaze of SCP 5967 onto Alpha
the team's field commander ordered Delta
to open fire taking out Caesar Winters
in a single shot but only for a moment
another of the commune members kneeled
over and began convulsing a wound formed
at the person's neck and from it emerged
Caesar Winter's face it grew into a
full-sized head replacing that of the
commune member giving Winters a brand
new body in moments on Alpha's orders to
stop Winters from hopping to more bodies
gamma and the others in their team fired
on the other cultists everyone was
terminated 15 seconds was all it took
then they moved towards SCP
5967 and everything went wrong the
bodies started to convulse violently as
if some unseen hand was shaking them
around like ragd dolls gamma watched as
they began to levitate hoisted by the
their necks and floating towards the
mobile task force not one of them knew
what to do keeping their rifles up and
trained on the corpses each one folded
in on itself becoming compressed masses
of muscle embedded with eyes that was
when the team lost Alpha something was
happening to their leader she had
dropped her weapon and Fallen to her
knees immediately gamma moved in to help
her commander trying to pull her back to
her feet but Alpha was resisting
transfixed by SCP 5967
it's her she is lost deep in the cosmos
and is angry with us for not helping her
find her way back she will kill us all
lest we line our brains and see her for
who she truly is GMA watched as her team
leaders rushed towards the pillar of
eyes and licked it the floating orbs of
Flesh and eyes that had once been people
suddenly hurdled towards the members of
MTF Lambda 5 at high speed gamma Dove
Clear at the vital moment performing a
tactical role and managing to narrowly
avoid being struck beta wasn't so lucky
ready to retaliate gamma raises a weapon
to fire at the floating remains only to
hear Alpha ordering her to stop she had
stopped licking SCP
5967 but whatever influence had
compromised the mobile task force leader
hadn't relinquished its hold over her
she grinned unnervingly as her eyes
rolled back into her head don't you hear
her voice she is angry but I can save
you I can save us let me show you Alpha
said before charging at Gamma with her
arms outstretched in seconds before she
could defend against her commanding
officer gamma found herself pounced upon
by Alpha grabbing a nearby Rock Alpha
swung at her head and knocked gamma's
tactical helmet clean off pinning her
down possessed by some unknown anomalous
entity Alpha held open gamma's eyelids
and licked her eyeball gamma screamed in
horror as Alpha looked up to the sky and
yelled I can see you I can see
everything now the case of SCP 5967 is
one of the stranger Tales within the
annals of the SCP foundation's history
their investigation that led to the
discovery of these 5ft tall pillars of
eyes and muscle originally began with a
different intention the commune had been
making waves in Lindhurst New Jersey the
kind of waves that had caught the SCP
foundation's attention the two leaders
of this apparent cult were Salem steros
and Caesar Winters both of whom seem to
be able to use SCP 5967 to take control
of the local residents Minds anyone that
they affected could be controlled
remotely by either steros or Winters
with a seemingly unlimited range and no
known way of relinquishing their control
over an affected person amnestic
treatments hypnotherapy none of the
foundation's usual methods had worked
undercover Foundation operatives working
secretly within the lindur Police
Department were the first to discover an
instance of SCP
5967 right under their noses literally
the pillar of eyeballs seemed to have
sprouted up right in the middle of the
lind HST police station the foundation
sent in containment teams to secure the
area and administer amnestics to
Witnesses but just how were steros and
Winters causing these monstrous
musculature monoliths to appear well the
pair operated a radio show together
known as the reality SC
the foundation agents within Lindhurst
had been unable to track down exactly
where they were broadcasting from
however after the SCP 5967 instance
appeared within the police station the
answer seemed to present itself during
the building's reconstruction tapes of
their radio show were recovered seeming
to suggest that the pair had been
utilizing anomalous means to broadcast
the reality sink from within the station
itself while keeping themselves
concealed the reality sink was a
religious talk show specifically focused
on discussing elements of fifth ISM with
the audience and callers who phoned into
Winters and steros hidden Studio what
exactly is fifth ISM well there's no
easy answer to that question
unfortunately other anomalous Cults and
religions at least have a core tenant or
belief at their Center sarcasm is the
worship of disease and Decay while
mechanites from the church of the broken
God venerate technology the beliefs of
the fifth church are a little more
interchange able however they don't
really have any defined theology or
religious practices fism is often more
just a collection of recurring ideas and
motifs the number five stars and the
belief in an external Cosmic God often a
malicious one in fact if there is a
defining principle of fifth ISM it's
that it's an anomalous way of thinking
that it can't really be understood
practitioners of fism are concerned
primarily with transcending reality as
we perceive it they are highly
interested in entities and anomalies
that can warp and shape reality to the
extent of even being fearful of such
beings a lot of fifthist seek to not
only spread their influence to others
through any means necessary including
brainwashing but also hope to transcend
Humanity to a higher plane of reality
The Fifth Dimension there in theory a
person would cease to be a human being
and wouldn't even really be akin to a
god or powerful reality Bender instead
they would be becomes something more
vague a concept unable to be fully
defined or to exist in reality
completely fifths follow this goal
presumably with the intention of saving
humankind from reality warping anomalies
and they'll use any infectious
brainwashing Methods at their disposal
to bring as many people as they can into
their way of thinking this brings us
neatly back to Caesar Winters and Salem
steros Radio Show the reality sync this
was the communes that their particular
sect of fifth ism's way of spreading
what they referred to as the truth based
on the various fragmented cassette
recordings of their show that the SCP
Foundation were able to recover both
steros and Winters believed in a many
armed goddess referring to it as only
she or her they encouraged their
listeners to pray to this entity and let
her know that they were loyal to her
during one of their recovered broadcasts
the pair of fifth hosts were even able
to prank call the SC P Foundation itself
one Junior researcher Jones was
contacted by the two men and ridiculed
for his association with the SCP
Foundation but after a few jokes at
Junior researcher Jones's expense steros
and Winters began to insidiously implant
ideas of fifth ISM in the researcher's
head they referred to this as giving
Jones the truth something they both
intended to do for all of their
listeners in order to save them when
asked what they really meant Winters and
steros made vague illusions to the truth
being an infinite knowledge that only
she could bestow Jones had no idea who
she was meant to be our Guiding Light
our creator Salem described before
adding the very thoughts that should be
infiltrating your head right now it
seemed that through this call The Two
Hosts had managed to successfully embed
their fifth Concepts into the mind of
Junior researcher Jones and they weren't
about to stop there during another call
on their show both hosts spoke with a
Wallington New Jersey resident named
Wendy Ricefield who was already a
self-proclaimed fifthist steros and
Winters talked Wendy through a ritual to
learn the truth involving her drawing
sigils on the walls and floor of her
home and lighting candles the phone line
picked up wet squelching noises coming
from the other side the splintering of
wood and Wendy screaming for help as she
tried to run from her home only for
something to drag her back inside
eventually the foundation made the
executive decision to step in and deal
with the situ situation in New Jersey
directly steros and winters's operation
was getting out of hand more and more
people in the surrounding area were
being brainwashed into believing in
fifthist Concepts and compelled to
complete bizarre rituals sending a team
in to apprehend the cult leaders
Foundation Personnel discovered Salem
steros and numerous other members of the
commune they had gathered at an instance
of SCP 5967 that had manifested in
Wallington the same place that Wendy
Ricefield had been from stero and his
Fifth's followers were discovered
holding hands and standing in a circle
around the anomalous pillar of eyeballs
as well as approaching it and licking
SCP
5967 the members of the commune were
rounded up and most were sent to be kept
in isolation at site 9 however Salem
steros was brought to site 83 for
questioning Junior researcher Umar Hadid
conducted an interview as to the exact
nature of the Goddess her that steros
and Winters often referred to to and the
anomalous rituals that per had been
involved with Salem was less than
Cooperative he demanded to be set free
in the interest of saving people by
spreading the truth with Caesar however
he did reveal some key information about
her according to steros his claims she
was a goddess actively meddling with
reality and influencing human actions he
told Hadid that if he killed the junior
researcher right there it would be
because she willed it some time before
both Salem and his cult co-leader Caesar
had been stargazing in the Meadowlands a
remote field in East Rutherford that's
when they had allegedly heard her voice
and being told the truth this reality
warping goddess was intending to return
home but that way was broken so
according to steros she needed their
help this was the reason he and Winters
began creating instances ofp
5967 the eyeball pillars apparently
acted as beacons like a GP PS signal
allowing her to come back the pair and
the rest of the commune were attempting
to prove their loyalty to her in the
hopes that they would potentially be
allowed to transcend reality in
accordance with the fifths principle
Salem steros was remained into SCP
Foundation custody and kept detained in
a containment Suite surrounded by three
Scranton reality anchors shortly after
the members of MTF Lambda 5 were
dispatched heading to the location
steros had inadvertently revealed during
his interrogation their mission was to
arrest Caesar Winters who remained at
large after the leader of Lambda 5 was
compromised eventually gamma was able to
contact the foundation who sent a
containment team as backup they secured
the surviving MTF operative along with
the infected team leader Alpha and the
instance of SCP 5967 on the scene gamma
was offered medical treatment and
presented with a silver lion badge for
her efforts in the field along with a
twoe vacation as a reward that did
little to stop the nightmares though she
wasn't the same and neither was Alpha
after two long weeks of psychological
screening and no further hostile or
anomalous activity Alpha was interviewed
by Junior researcher Hadid during their
discussion Alpha real name Cassandra
Sandy danowski described that she could
still hear voices in her head rambling
about the truth fifth ISM and eyeballs
amnestic treatment wasn't helping
suddenly someone within the foundation
played a clip of Caesar winters's voice
over the facility speakers taken from
one of his and steros radio broadcasts
it triggered an instant paranoid
reaction from Sandy followed by her
opening her mouth and revealing
something growing inside another eyeball
some kind of post hypnotic suggestion or
other form of brainwashing had affected
her and she began exhibiting anomalous
Behavior tell me Hadid are you a
fifthist now she asked the junior
researcher are you ready to see the
truth Hadid rushed out of the room
shutting the door behind him pacing
around the room Sandy started drawing
strange sigils of Unknown Origin on the
floor and walls lighting a candle
through anomalous means then there came
a bright flash of light as a four-legged
entity appeared and attacked Alpha the
two merged causing her body to change
until it was unrecognizable well as
human anyway standing in the
interrogation room where Sandy had been
standing was a contorted mass of Flesh
and muscle with multiple eyeballs
staring out from it she had turned into
another instance of SCP
5967 they all had they were people
steros and Winters had made beacons out
of living people researcher Martin
pushed the deck against the door hoping
it would hold long enough for him to
find an alternate Escape Route he wasn't
thinking about the long term he couldn't
afford to with the foundation's global
reach he'd never truly Escape them never
be able to make it away condemned to
spend the rest of his life on the run
from the organization he devoted his
life to it was too overwhelming to even
attempt to reckon with that especially
with the pounding of a fist against the
door he scrabbled around opening Windows
to try and see if there was a safe way
down technically none of this was his
fault at least in his mind the
administrative login information he'd
used to access the file shouldn't have
been left so easy to find that was just
poor cyber security on the foundation's
part researcher Martin had been tasked
with compiling information on SCP 001
one of the most infamous anomalies ever
encountered in the foundation's long and
storied history or multiple of them at
least what Martin had come to learn was
there were numerous entities within the
foundation's files that all acted as
proposals for SCP 001 some were
creatures the typical kind of anomalous
entities the foundation dealt with on a
regular basis but some of the proposals
focused on more abstract anomalies and
somehow those were more existentially
terrifying than any evil Godlike being
bent on destroying reality theories
about the very source of anomalies
themselves that their very existence
might have been predetermined by some
otherworldly Force then there were the
other proposals that named parts of the
foundation as the true as SCP 001 those
seem to suck researcher Martin in like a
vortex dragging him down a deep dark
rabbit hole that made him start to
question everything he thought he knew
about working for the SCP Foundation and
the one that had toppled him into a
full-blown conspiracy obsessed stuper
that there was no coming back from the
Noir Box's proposal the weighted head of
a battering ram splintered the wooden
surface of the door spraying fragments
over the room the table propped up to
keep it shut toppled under the force of
the entry as a squad of shadowy figures
in full black combat gear gear rushed
inside the mobile task force surrounded
the cowering researcher keeping their
weapons trained on him researcher Martin
pleading for his life started gesturing
to the walls of the room around him that
had been plastered with hastily scrolled
diagrams and equations Martin tried
desperately to find some concise easy to
understand way of explaining to the
soldiers what he'd uncovered they only
picked up on a few words like many
worlds hypothesis and splitting
universes But ultimately they didn't
follow what he was saying and weren't
sent there to hear him out all the MTF
had been told was that researcher Martin
had breached Foundation security and now
posed a risk of exposing sensitive
information about SCP 001 there was only
one path of recourse termination however
unbeknownst to them Dr Martin was fine
at least a version of him was one who
never learned about the Noir box
proposal for SCP 001 and hadn't gone mad
trying to unravel ITS m iies instead he
was a respected higher ranking member of
the foundation who was alive and well in
a completely different timeline the
formation of the SCP Foundation has
always been shrouded in mystery with
nobody really knowing what the true
origin of the organization is and what
is merely just a cover story left in the
archives to keep the truth hidden SCP
001 the Noir boox proposal at least
might hold the answers to the questions
surrounding how the foundation came to
be three times over known as the
tindalos Trinity the file pertaining to
this anomaly is buried deep in the SCP
foundation's database under layers upon
layers of encryption and security
clearance requirements it requires
someone at the very top level of the
foundation to access a member of either
the overseer Council or the foundation's
high command or OverWatch but wait what
are those aren't they the same thing
well yes and no the exact name of the
high-ranking secretive group that runs
the foundation has often been
interchangeable whether they're known as
the 05 Council the overseer Council Etc
but what if it wasn't just many
different names for the same governing
body but actually separate names for
alternate versions of the ones who
control the SCP Foundation allow us to
explain all three of these groups the
overseer Council High command and
OverWatch have come to a consensus that
SCP 001 is an anomaly that connects with
the foundation's very origin they
believe that the founder of the SCP
Foundation also known as SCP 001 was
anomalous in some way that caused them
to interact with time in an unusual
fashion the triumvir of councils are in
agreement that around the time that the
SCP Foundation was formed three distinct
timelines were generated given the
anomalous nature of the organization's
founder each of these timelines
drastically altered the nature nature of
SCP 001 featuring a different version in
each one in the first commonly known as
timeline HC where the foundation is run
by a high command SCP 001 was an
anomalous human corpse this timeline's
SCP 001 still exhibited all the
behavioral characteristics of a normal
human being but could additionally
replicate itself at an erratic
uncontrollable rate usually when
performing tasks that could have
multiple possible outcomes as CP 001 in
Timeline HC also interacted
anachronistically with its environment
passing through solid matter that
predated it or would Outlast it so it
had to be contained in a room that was
constructed before it existed as an
anomaly this timeline's SCP 001 was
responsible for conceiving the idea for
the SCP Foundation and was able to
promote a significant interest in the
organization however they were
assassinated before the foundation was
officially codified with the culprits
being a version of mobile task force Alp
zero who are believed to have originated
from either of the other two timelines
while this seems to have been done to
deter the foundation forming in this
timeline it seems to have had the
opposite effect despite the
assassination of SCP 001 occurring
before the official formation of the SCP
Foundation in Timeline HC this version
of the foundation was successfully
codified by the 13 members of what they
refer to as high command giv in the
anomalous circumstances around the death
of SCP 001 it provided a catalyst for
the organization to immediately
establish itself as this timeline's
protection against the threat posed by
anomalous entities the body of SCP 001
was placed in the building that had been
its childhood home securing it somewhere
that predated them to negate their
anomalous properties this made them the
first anomaly contained by timeline hc's
version of the SCP Foundation cume
continuously garnering them the official
designation of SCP 001 so that's the
first of our three timelines at play the
events that unfold in the second are
considerably different in this timeline
timeline OC the foundation was initially
created by a different as SCP 001 this
entity referred to primarily as the
founder appropriately enough was a human
being known to possess anomalous
temporal abilities the founder was known
to also be immortal showing no visible
signs of aging and with a resistance to
external damage that prevented him from
being directly killed any injuries he
sustained could be healed but only at
the same rate typical of an average
human being the temporal side of his
anomalous properties pertained to
predicting the future the founder was
able to with an inarguable level of
precision and accuracy forecast events
before they occurred his foresight it
appeared to the foundation was not
inciting these events to happen as he
predicted them however ever everything
he ever predicted would occur became an
inevitability impossible to delay avert
or alter through any means during the
events of timeline OC and as his
preferred nickname implies the founder
was the sole figure responsible for
establishing this version of the SCP
Foundation in this course of events the
05 Council of this timeline were known
as the overseer Council it was however
while he was in the process of
establishing the organization that
things started to go around
whether he was able to predict this
occurrence or not is unknown although it
seems to have corresponded with the MTF
Alp zero assassination of SCP 001 in the
other timeline timeline HC in Timeline
OC at the same time as the assassination
in Timeline HC the founder began to
exhibit his anomalous temporal
properties in front of the original
members of overseer Council however it
should also be noted that there was no
recorded presence of MTF Alp zero in
Timeline OC believing the founder to be
a potential danger to the foundation
they had all helped to create the
founding overseer Council classified him
as an anomalous threat they immediately
devised a set of containment measures
for the founder now designating him as
SCP 001 the first anomaly contained by
this timeline's version of the
foundation he was placed within a
standard humanoid containment cell and
given regular meals while Personnel were
forbidden to communicate with him given
his role in establishing the foundation
in this version of events SCP 001 is
naturally in favor of containing and
analyzing anomalies however not when
that includes him and insisted that he
be released according to one of his
predictions for forthcoming events he
requested to be allowed to build a
device but refused to elaborate on the
intended purpose of it SCP 001 even
refused to allow other members of
foundation Personnel to construct the
device on his behalf for testing
purposes the third of these these
timelines is referred to as timeline o
where in the leading body of the
foundation are known as OverWatch here
just like the previous iterations of its
history the description of SCP 001 and
their role in forming the SCP Foundation
differs in this timeline SCP 001 is an
anomaly that consists of two distinct
Parts the first of these is a figure not
to similar from the founder referred to
as SCP
0011 this person is also a functionally
immortal human who doesn't age and can't
heal rapidly from damage SCP 01-1 also
advocates for securing and analyzing
anomalies however this includes himself
as he doesn't object to his own
containment or that of the second
component of this SCP 001 known as SCP
001a this device is capable of
accurately calculating any and all
possible outcomes of any event that is
input into it unlike the founder who
seem to possess possess a foresight able
to predict the only inevitable outcome
of the future SCP 001a is able to
account for the possibility of multiple
potential Futures even down to
accounting for how its own predictions
could potentially influence or alter
outcomes in layman's terms at least one
of the eventualities predicted by SCP
001a will always be accurate unless the
predictions are to do with its own
future or the future of SCP
0011 in this instance the device will
always produce one of two assumptions
that are incorrect either that SCP 001
D1 was killed after an assassination
attempt and never constructed SC SCP 001
d a but that's impossible after all SCP
001a exists it's already been made in
this timeline the other incorrect
prediction it can give is that SCP 00
1-1 also exhibits the same anomalous
properties as the prediction machine
more akin to the founder and that SCP 00
1-A was never constructed in the first
place but again that can't be right in
this timeline anyway according to
records within timeline ow their version
of the founder who is of course A CP
0011 encountered a version of mobile
task force Alp Zero from one of the
other timelines they presented the
founder of the ow timeline with detailed
blueprints for the construction of SCP
001a the devic's completion coincided
with the assassination in Timeline HC
and the corresponding anomalous incident
in Timeline OC after this point MTF
alzero departs from timeline ow this
version of the SCP Foundation is then
created to study the device SCP 001 D
with this founder and a group of his
close friends who would become this
foundation's OverWatch following this
initial research group's discovery of
other anomalous phenomenon that
threatened the rest of society the
team's goal expanded to research
anomalies and protect the world from the
danger they posed however the rest of
the OverWatch began to age at a natural
rate while the founder didn't recognize
this he volunteered to be contained and
studied thus becoming a component of
this timeline's SCP 001 stepping back
and looking at all these timelines there
seems to be a number of marked
similarities particularly relating to
how the foundation was established and
how a figure usually the one who founded
the organization possessed anomalous
means means of interacting with time and
temporality under normal circumstances
interaction between alternate timelines
should be impossible but the
preservation of information about all
three on the SCP foundation's database
has somehow enabled all three timelines
to communicate with each other through
exchanging intelligence via their own
versions of the database all three
iterations of the foundation across the
three timelines have learned that almost
all of the anomalies they have
encountered since being established are
exclusive to their own timeline there
are a total of 17 anomalies that have
been confirmed to exist across the three
timelines but there is a concerning
factor in all this the presence of an
anachronistic military group referring
to itself as MTF Alp zero this mobile
task Force's direct involvement in the
events of both timeline HC where they
assassinated SCP 001 and timeline ow
where they provided schematics for SCP
001a raises an awful lot of questions
question s this MTF had to be acting on
orders of the foundation but which
version in which timeline the consensus
among the leading Committees of all
three the high command overseer Council
and OverWatch is that at some unknown
date in the future each of them will
inevitably send their own version of MTF
Alp zero back in time to alter the
foundation's past and in a sense they've
already done it and seen how this
altered the circumstances in order to
inadvertently create the foundation but
this poses the risk of one of these
timelines overriding another thus
meaning all information garnered by
alternate iterations of the foundation
could be lost so putting their heads
together these Foundation leading
committees come to the conclusion that
they need to attempt to merge all three
timelines and it seems the way to do so
is using the device that timeline OC's
founder wanted to build and that
timeline 's founder was able to
construct this device is how the this
proposal for
scp1 was given its nickname the Noir box
the intention of the Noir box is to
shunt all three timelines into a stable
joint path like turning loose strands
into a single length of twine as such
the leading committies of all three
different timelines have agreed to share
their Intel on how each of them can
safely create their own Noir boxes and
all three will be used to merge the
timelines every member of high command
the overseer Council
and OverWatch sign off on it but whether
or not the plan works is another matter
the fabric of time is delicate and one
wrong move could tear everything apart
the sr47 sniper rifle slotted together
effortlessly even after so many years of
combat usage the weapon was in pristine
condition in all the time agent Harris
had owned the gun though the thousands
of times she'd fired it not once had it
ch dammed and that was fortunate because
she had to move quickly in a clearing
about 300 M in front of her were their
targets capable of teleporting in a
split second she needed to be sure that
her team would be able to finish the job
quickly and efficiently she looked
through the scope slotted onto her rifle
and kicked out the bipod resting it on a
tree stump now she just had to wait for
the signal she looked all around the
marsh trying her best to spot her fellow
agents but they were also well
camouflaged even though she knew the
exact spot where they would be she
couldn't see anyone she'd always wanted
to see the Himalayas it had been on her
bucket list to climb Mount Everest as a
child but the world had changed since
then Mount Everest was gone in fact the
majority of Nepal had vanished replaced
by an enormous Marsh full almost
exclusively of pink Ferns and Droopy
trees that seemed to Sag to one side
unable to support their own weight the
most striking natural wonder on planet
Earth had been replaced by a landscape
that was flat wet and alien agent Harris
curled her finger around the trigger and
took aim through her sights 2 minutes
passed then the gentle whistle of a
sparrow drifted over to her in the humid
air except of course it couldn't be a
sparrow to the best of her knowledge
sparrows had gone extinct with a snarl
of anger agent Harris squeezed the
trigger she felt the silent sniper rifle
kick her shoulder if they wanted War
they sure as had hell would get it the
destruction of the world began in 2078
its designation was SCP orange Das a and
as often happens with these kind of
things no one saw it coming the SCP
Foundation having dedicated decades to
researching potential World destroying
events was totally blindsided by what
happened the day the weasels showed up
weasels you ask that's right but before
we explain a question for you is
something interfering with your
happiness or preventing you from
achieving your goals regardless if you
have a clinical mental health issue like
depression or anxiety or if you're just
a human who lives in this world who is
going through a hard time therapy can
give you tools to approach your life in
a very different way and that's why I'm
excited to tell you about today's
sponsor better help better help's
mission is to make therapy more
affordable and more accessible and this
is an important Mission because finding
a therapist can be really hard
especially when you're limited to the
options in your area better help is a
platform that makes finding a therapist
EAS easier because it's online it's
remote and by filling out a few
questions better help can match you to a
professional therapist in as little as a
few days it's easy to sign up and get
matched with a therapist there's a link
in my description it's betterhelp.com
slcp exlained clicking that link helps
support this channel but it also gets
you 10% off your first month of better
help so you can connect with a therapist
and see if it helps you and because
finding a therapist is a little like
dating if you don't really fit with that
therapist which is a common thing with
therapy you can easily switch to a new
therapist at no additional cost without
stressing about insurance who's in your
network or anything like that so if
you're struggling consider online
therapy with better help click the link
in the description or visit
betterhelp.com
sccp exlained thank you again better
help for supporting this Channel and now
as we were saying about the weasels a
man called Harland stump was the first
human to make contact with the weasels
he was the groundskeeper at site 59
Harland was making his usual weekly
trips around the perimeter of the
courtyard on his ride along lawnmower
watching baseball on his phone all the
way when out of nowhere the aliens
appeared just 2 m in front of him a
squadron of 11 weasels materialized the
weasels designated SCP
orange-based composed of a head primary
thorax secondary thorax tessary thoracic
cloy abdomen and tail with a hard
segmented shell covering their backs and
no apparent sensory organs aside from a
radula on their heads they are an
intimidating presence most striking
about them however is the most delicate
part of their appearance on their backs
each weasel has an array of Flora
growing in a kind of garden it appears
that each weasel has a different array
of flowers growing from their backs
understanding the meaning of these
Gardens can be difficult but it appears
the more extravagant it is the higher
ranking the individual weasel is the 11
weasels that appeared before Harland
stump each had a very vibrant Garden
indeed but no more so than the weasel
held a loft in an ornate palaquin
Harland stump stopped Mowing and stared
at the aliens for approximately 13
seconds at which point he let out a sigh
pressed play on his baseball game and
continued mowing the lawn he spent too
many years groundskeeping site 59 to get
spooked by anything as harmless as giant
teleporting insects just three more
weeks and he would be retired until then
he was avoiding nonsense like the plague
except his phone had disappeared Harland
stared down at the empty space confusion
knitting his eyebrows together before
looking up and seeing the handset in the
hands of the alien sitting on its Regal
Throne the smartphone made a loud
screeching noise and then all of a
sudden began to flick between Snippets
of YouTube videos each clip lasting just
a couple of seconds after a moment Haron
realized that the alien was using the
videos to speak to him the words were
being picked out from all these
different videos to stitch together a
sentence barely H ho neighborino this is
foundation reports indicate Foundation
is locally the Masters of the Universe
isn't that right darling question mark
Keen to finish his Mo and avoid further
nonsense Harlin had to concede that he
should probably talk to these aliens if
only to get phone back he told them he
liked the Gardens on their backs why
thank you gardening is kind of our thing
well quick question is your species
capable of dying M Harland G he'd been
around long enough to see where this was
going the conversation was brief Harlen
kept glancing at his phone desperately
hoping that these aliens hadn't somehow
broken it and that it hadn't lost his
place in the match until all of a sudden
Harland stump disappeared as did his
ride on lawn mower his smartphone and a
patch of lawn replaced by a roughly 10 m
circle of Antarctic ice and snow no one
is certain yet how the weasels are able
to do it all that is known is that they
can the phenomenon came to be known as
juxtaposing matter from one location
could be instantaneously switched with
matter from a different location it is
how the weasels first arrived on planet
Earth triggering the event of SCP 001
orange Das a orange Das a lasted for
just 2 hours but it changed the course
of humanity Forever on the 29th of April
2078 48.5 2% of the Earth's habitable
surface area dematerialized and
rematerialized half a kilometer above
the South Pole cities and towns from all
across planet Earth one by one
disappeared and reappeared in the air
above the South Pole where they promptly
fell 500 M causing backto back seismic
events Washington DC Beijing and London
were targeted first first followed by
Tokyo Delhi and then a number of Capital
Cities from Europe this toour window
resulted in freak weather events as -
50° pockets of air kilometers across
replac the disappearing cities it is
disputed as to who launched the first
nuclear warhead whether it was done by
accident out of fear or as a strategic
attack against a group of weasels orange
daset was simply too chaotic and
destructive for Humanity ever to be able
to know what happened in that short
period of time the result however was a
number of nuclear explosions raging
across the planet before the cities in
charge of launching them were also
transported to the South Pole while the
weasels were capable of experiencing
juxtaposition without any apparent
physical harm terrestrial life forms
were less fortunate during the process
of juxtaposition the bonds between each
and every cell are broken while organic
life does get transported to the new
location it undergos immediate
liquefaction not a single earthborn life
form has been observed surviving a
juxtaposition event in that 2-hour
window 6.9 billion people were killed
Humanity had lost this event triggered
the use of project yellow an emergency
evacuation protocol that occurs at the
point where the survival of the human
race seems to be virtually zero a small
band of specially chosen individuals
were evacuated to a pocket Dimension
where they were put into cryosleep to
wait until the Earth was habitable once
again in the days following the events
of orange Das a the true Invasion began
choosing the Sahara Desert as their
arrival point the weasel started to
appear in Legions millions and millions
of them filled the Desert Sands and went
about populating their new planet but
what was their purpose well fortunately
we've been able to salvage a modest
amount of data that can inform us of why
they're here and what their plans are
the weasel that first appeared to
Harland stump just outside site 59 has
been designated SC SCP orange prime it
is believed that this we in particular
is their leader whether Prime is simply
the leader of this Colony or The Wider
species is yet to be confirmed security
cameras were able to capture the
interaction as it took place within SC
159's grounds in their conversation
orange Prime explains their purpose to
Harland through YouTube clips on his
phone long story short weasel have come
from home World dimension for fulfill a
long-standing mutual agreement with
Grandma this is one of many new homes
this is a pretty nice place for weasel
this land is my land from California to
the New York Islands from the Redwood
Forest to the Gulf Stream Waters this
land was made for weasles two Garden two
Farm two create Beauty two spread Good
Vibes two cultivate two remake two
terraform etc etc since this encounter
no human has been able to get close
enough to Orange Prime to engage the
weasel in further conversation this
snippet of footage is all that Humanity
has to understand why this alien species
has slaughtered billions of us 4 months
later agent Harris lay flat in the
marshin firing her sniper rifle at the
weasels gathering in a clearing ahead of
them their operation looked like
Overkill it always did it was of utmost
importance that they strike quickly and
without Mercy sustained heavy gunfire
from all sides combined with RPG fire
and the use of incendiary weapons made
short work of the weasels all of these
weapons were necessary to pierce the
heavy armor that covered their backs but
that was the reason it felt like
Overkill it felt that way because the
weasels never fought back they would not
attack defend themselves help their
fallen allies or even beg for their
lives they would simply stand idly by as
they were gunned down that is a until
the incendiary grenades arrived the pink
ferns filling the marshlands caught fire
and began to curl and smoke heavily as
soon as that happened the weasel sprung
into action quickly splashing water onto
the leaves trying their best to save the
plants the incendiary grenades were not
necessary they did very little damage to
the weasels themselves the reason the
platoon used the grenades was that it
was one way they had found to distress
their Alien Invaders in any way it was a
small Revenge they could take for the
billions of people who had lost their
lives over the prior few months agent
Harris pumped five extra shots into the
corpse of a weasel before standing down
and going to examine her handiwork they
had been hunting orange Prime rumors had
suggested that their primary target had
been lurking in the Himalayan region but
that had obviously proven to be false
among all the bodies on the ground there
was no sign of the fearless leader
frustration boiled in Harris as she
kicked a corpse the thick shell hurt her
foot she must have broken her toong toe
at that moment a rustling noise came
from the other side of the trees soon
dozens more hundreds more weasels were
walking through the marsh in a split
second her platoon opened fire Tracer
rounds lashed through the trees and the
orange glow of fire danced in every
direction but there were more weasels
many more of them agent Harris felt her
stomach knot as she fired her rifle into
the crowd there were too many simply too
many they were going to run out of ammo
before they had a chance to shoot down
each and every one of them them and she
was right the firefight lasted for 30
minutes before the remaining Soldier ran
out of ammunition dozens of weasel
bodies litter the marsh floating in the
water dozens more weasels stood
encircling the group that's when the
humming started whenever a jux toos
event occurs it is always accompanied by
the weasel's humming to themselves it is
unclear whether this is the cause of the
jux deposition or simply a ritual that
they perform but every Soldier has come
to know that sound and each one of them
fears it in the pit of the their stomach
so they started to disappear all around
her one by one replaced by puffs of cold
air with snowflakes still gently hanging
in the breeze the human population of
planet Earth dwindled as the weasel
population bloomed large swaths of the
planet were terraformed one by one to
make room for alien Flora the South Pole
became a larger and larger Dumping
Ground for all the detrius that had once
been the most celebrated works of the
human race the Mona Lisa was torn and
forgotten buried under many kilometers
of concrete exposed sewage works and
apartment complexes and the situation
only got worse in October acting against
prior instructions from the foundation
the global ult Coalition launched
project Popco a 200 Megaton nuclear
warhead directly at a large weasel
population Center as the Warhead began
its descent the entire Sky turned a
solid dark blue project Popco
immediately fell out of contact as did
all satellites that had been orbiting
the planet the sun moon and stars could
not be scene the entire sky was just a
uniform dark blue in a desperate attempt
to find out what was going on the
foundation launched a man rocket in the
direction of poco's most recent
coordinates contact with the rocket was
lost after just 9 minutes this is the
most recent known account of events from
inside that rocket all of a sudden just
a few minutes into the flight warning
alarm started going off all over the
cockpit the radar was picking up a solid
object blocking their path gathering
around the readouts the crew came to a
very quick conclusion that the dark blue
that had been filling the sky was
actually a solid object that was
encasing the Earth but rather than abort
the mission the crew decided to
persevere having witnessed so Much Death
and destruction over the previous year
they knew they would much rather go out
and crashing a rocket into a blue wall
then join the billions of humans
liquefied in a pile in Antarctica
closing their eyes bracing for impact
the crew Reed themselves for their now
inevitable deaths but it didn't come
instead the rocket was able to force it
way through the dense blue object
falling apart as it went Ground Control
lost contact with the ship nothing and
then a few seconds of audio the crew had
made it they had somehow managed to
pierce their way through the blue shell
that was surrounding their planet and
were out into not space the Earth the
entire planet had been ju opposed philan
be the welcome to an exclusive behind
the scenes look at Heaven boom on May
12th 2588 the town of Kangas Greenland
was destroyed by a devastating 4 kiloton
explosion accompanied by a massive
electromagnetic pulse the few survivors
that made it through the incident alive
described seeing a pale green light in
the area at the time of the explosion
shortly after an omka class scenario or
endof death scenario began in which all
multicellular life on Earth began to
experience a regenerative effect
regardless of injury or illness in other
words nobody could die anymore this
resulted in intense worldwide panic in
the face of the inexplicable occurrence
as the Panic mounted the 05 Council of
the FCP Foundation held an emergency
meeting in order to address the
possibilities at hand meanwhile
civilians began reporting sightings of a
gigantic pale white humanoid monster
rampaging through their cities and
communities wrecking havoc and violently
attacking anyone and anything in its
path as the situation progressed and
worsened and the reality of the end of
death scenario began to set in the SCP
Foundation made the difficult decision
to lift its veil of secrecy and reveal
itself to the world 05- one made a
statement to the UN regarding the
reality of the worldwide anomaly
advising citizens to remain calm and
await further instructions 5 days after
the world learned the truth of the SCP
Foundation the pale monster arrived in
St John's new land where it was met by
mobile task force new7 hammerdown for
what they hoped would be a quick fight
and neutralization instead 2 years of
devastating bloody combat ensued by July
4th 2590 90% of the Task Force personnel
had been killed and regenerated an
average of five times at this point MTF
news7 abandoned the city of St John
citing anomalously poor working
conditions after being held in place for
2 years the monster was able to break
through the defensive line and continue
its Rampage on October 10th 2590 the SCP
Foundation and the global occult
Coalition came together in an act of
unprecedented cooperation to found
project Beluga dedicated to the goal of
neutralizing the monster designated SCP
ubu and stopping its reign of terror but
project Beluga was unable to neutralized
The Entity before it reached Columbus
Ohio on December 29th 2590 once it
arrived in the city SCP ubu began
dedicating its time to a gruesome
personal project first it dug a two km
deep hole in the city's Center next it
gathered a total of 2.9 Million
civilians throwing them into the hole
after the hole was full The Entity
leaped into the upper Stratosphere over
and over again stomping into the hole
each time when the people inside were
pulverized The Entity destroyed a large
Fountain which it used as a cup and
drank the resulting juices from the hole
this entire process took roughly 1 year
and when it was finished the entity
appeared to grow bored with Columbus and
moved to Lake Erie upon reaching Lake
Erie SCP ubu trudged out into the water
and began assaulting the cargo ship
stock there it began lifting ships up
and throwing them out of the water some
flying high enough to exit Earth's
gravitational pole altogether two of the
ships were later spotted on the surface
of the Moon this chaos and destruction
continued for years and years until June
10th
2670 when SCP ubu was contained at SCP
Foundation site 59 however this
containment only lasted for 2 minutes at
which point The Entity escaped and made
its way to New York City where it was
found howling and attempted to defile
the Statue of Liberty several countries
used their nuclear arsenals to attack
SCP ubu over the course of its Rampage
until this connectic agreement was
signed on February 10th
2674 cementing an agreement between NATO
Powers the Russian Federation the
People's Republic of China and the
global occult Coalition all signatories
agreed that due to concerns around the
environment any additional nuclear
strikes against the entity would be
prohibited after the signing was
finished SCP ubu crashed the ceremony
grabbing several lengths of rebar and 15
forign dignitaries which it used to
construct itself a bead necklace the
next notable incident occurred when SCP
ubu showed up at site 19 interrupting a
round of testing with SCP AF a woman
capable of turning matter into stone by
speaking to it SCP ubu broke through the
ceiling crushing AFF beneath its weight
SCP 682 which was also present
approached the entity curiously and SCP
ubu responded by angrily defecating and
shouting at SCP 682 in gibberish SCP 682
seemed to understand this vocalization
and attacked SCP ubu demanding that it
take back the insult at this point SCP
ubu slapped 682 cheek causing 682 to let
out a horrific Scream the slap left
behind a glowing green Mark which spread
over the entity of 682s body before
breaking the bonds of its cells all at
once dissolving the reptile into a pool
of toxic fluid SCP ubu then spent 5
minutes bathing in this fluid while
giggling after finishing its bath
devouring the rec constituted SCP AF and
screaming into the microphone for 20
minutes SCP ubu broke into armed
containment area 179 and swallowed SCP
2317 hole on March 5th 2686 SCP ubu
conducted an assault on Thal class SCP
2000 rendering it neutralized again
years of Hell passed as project Beluga
struggled to come up with new methods
that had not already been exhausted
meanwhile civilians did their best to
find ways to cope with the state of the
world on March 25th 2750 former film
star Nash deg grut published the zon
Manifesto A book based around a simple
principle life on Earth was no longer
worth living consciously and the only
way formed was to enter an eternal coma
through the combination of chemicals and
guided meditation this kickstarted the
social movement the international zon on
June 24th 2790 project Beluga forces
managed to drive SCP ubu into the Bay of
Bengal where remained for 3 years
causing very little trouble aside from
underwater seismic events meanwhile the
international zong continued to grow and
one massive adherence known as cutopia
reached its goal of 5 million residents
on June 10th
2793 SCP ubu flung SCP 3000 out of the
ocean leaving it beached on the soil of
India several cities were destroyed in
this process The Entity then spent a
week pointing and laughing at The
Beached sea monster before grabbing it
by the tip of its tail and beginning to
drag it across Asia SCP U continued
carving a path through Asia the
wriggling SCP 3000 in tow until it
reached the bearing straight then it
began to cross the straight into Alaska
returning to North American territory
once more but it didn't stop there
instead advancing toward South America
until it and SCP 3000 arrived on the
eastern coast of Brazil on August 29th
2793 there it dragged its unfortunate
charge back into the ocean once more
disappearing from sight on August 30th
2793 SCP 169 or the Leviathan emerged
from the depths of the ocean there are
some reports that SCP 3000 had been tied
around its neck but these have not been
confirmed the Leviathan and SCP ubu then
entered into a lengthy battle which
carried on for several hundred years
after so much time had passed that
Witnesses could scarcely remember a time
when it wasn't happening the fight
between SCP ubu and SCP 169 came to a
halt much as it had with SCP 682 SCP ubu
slapped SCP 169 across the face with
such force that its cell bonds dissolved
and it melted into a puddle of fluid
which was lost beneath the ocean waves
SCP 169 was reclassified neutralized
December 11th 3020 marked the start of a
10-year period of inactivity for SCP ubu
ordinarily one would expect this to come
with a sense of relief however even in
spite of the global immortality the
collateral damage from SCP ubu's
centuries of Carnage had rendered the
surface of the Earth uninhabitable with
all land now underwater the remains of
human civilization persist on a single
archipelago of floating cities
constructed from ships and debris
meanwhile the international zon movement
has persisted gaining more and more
traction and popularity as conscious
life became less and less bearable an
enormous floating zon pile consisting of
international zon followers using
anomalous methods to achieve the perfect
zon began to form eventually this pile
earned the nickname new zland by May
28th 3028 the archipelago was abandoned
and the 140 remaining conscious humans
retreated to the SCP foundation's scps
nasmith there they lived in relative
safety for for several months until SCP
ubu was spotted in the water off the
port bow of the Nay Smith on January
14th 3030 it emitted several sounds that
Witnesses described as mocking before
swimming off towards new zonin in
response to this reappearance after 10
years of inactivity the 05 Council
called an emergency meeting the
transcript for this meeting reads as
follows we haven't exhausted all of our
nous options for neutralizing ubu
where's the corn CR we've been overse
sorence s the k this mess is only going
to it is anchored 57 clicks due
Southeast for why the hell did you tell
him that well friends it seems the Omega
K has had us up in about so long that
our personalities have run out of fuel
we were given from birth in all
likelihood we'd see better
professionalism and teamwork in new
zland as a matter of fact that's a good
segue into what I was about to propose
and frankly I hope you find the nicest
cleanest spots in the mass grave where
are you going that depends which way is
southeast at this point 05-11 left the
room presumably to track down the corn
CR leaving the remains of the 05 Council
there and leaving the remains of project
Beluga with the question of how to
handle
scpu according to its official SCP
Foundation file SCP ubu is an extremely
violent and hostile humanoid entity of
Unknown Origin which appeared in
Greenland on May 12th 2588 it displays
anomalous physical strength and speed
as well as reality bending capabilities
and the emission of regenerative Lambda
waves linked to the ongoing end of death
scenario the appearance of SCP ubu and
the start of the endof death scenario
coincided with several additional
phenomenon there was a mass loss of
function for all the objects operated by
the three moons initiative the three
moons initiative was an extradimensional
human organization based in SCP
2922 C or the afterlife known as
corbenic this organization was founded
14,000 years ago with the purpose of
establishing a human colony in the
afterlife and has long maintained a
peace treaty with the SCP Foundation SCP
2922 a method of communication that
allowed a human mind to make calls to
any pre-established phone number ceased
all functions next the extradimensional
space known as The Wanderer Library a
magical Archive of all the knowledge
from all known worlds and every book
that has ever been written will be
written and several that have have not
and will not exist was severed from
Earth when the SCP Foundation pressed
the Serpent's hand for answers a
representative answered that
irreconcilable security concerns
regarding Earth had come up and forced
them to make this decision a
representative of Marshall Carter and
dark limited somehow gained access to
the personal contact information of the
05 council's members and used this
information to reach out to them with a
business offer the company is ordinarily
on unfriendly terms with the SCP
Foundation due to their conflicting
interests namely Marshall Carter and
dark's interests in acquiring and
selling anomalous items entities and
experiences to the highest bidder
however in this case the company's
representative approached 05 council
members with a mixture of politeness and
Desperation begging the SCP Foundation
to purchase large amounts of the
company's stock the forest known as SCP
4000 lost all of its anomalous
properties all at once investigation
revealed only a small parchment note in
the area's entryway which read good luck
one of the most perplexing and
disconcerting phenomenon that occurred
concurrently with a SCP ubu's first
appearance was what happened to SCP 3
2008 the infinite Ikea though this sort
of thing should have been impossible the
infinite Ikea was anomalously purchased
by some unknown entity the Ikea branding
was stricken from the building and it
was converted into an emergency shelter
all of these occurrences combined to
serve as a warning something big is
coming and indeed it was
scpu it appears to be impervious to most
forms of damage including blunt force
trauma heavy caliber machine gun fire
temperatures up to, 1600° Kelvin
artillery fire and Direct Energy
discharge from other anomalies it did
express some discomfort when exposed to
severe simultaneous direct nuclear
strikes but it was not affected beyond
that the only recorded instance of
lasting damage to SCP UB was on August
14th 2784 in which the entity bit its
left thumb seemingly for no reason other
than curiosity after biting its thumb
The Entity scream for 7 days straight
then entered into a month-long crying
fit 30 years and 14 days later the thumb
had completely healed SCP ubu stands at
a height of 4.3 M while an exact measure
of its weight is unknown attemp at
measurement during its brief time in
containment showed that its weight is at
least 15,300 99 kg its exact anatomical
composition is unknown but a superficial
examination of the entity indicates that
its body shape resembles that of a large
androgenous humanoid covered in hairless
white skin similar in texture to that of
a dolphin or small whale The Entity has
no eyes ears or nostrils but seems to
still possess the ability to see hear
and smell its only visible sensory organ
aside from its skin is its5 M wide mouth
humanoid in nature with a prehensile
tongue of unknown length on its lower
body it has no apparent features aside
from a kowa that it uses to dispose of
waste SCP ubu is prone to vocalizations
mainly screaming laughing and babbling
but it does not appear to understand
speech in any known language nor does it
seem to be attempting to communicate
with anyone it encounters its primary
interest appears to be destruction and
causing as much of it as possible it
will attack anything that it can get get
its hands on but seems to show a
particular preference for attacking and
consuming human beings in large populous
areas such as cities its demeanor is
both sadistic and childlike and it has
been seen playing with its victims for
hours before moving on to a new Target
due to its regenerative effect present
in SCP ubu's vicinity it is incapable of
causing permanent damage to any living
thing and seems to have no greater
motivation Beyond causing fear and pain
SCP ubu is classified as Tiamat meaning
that it cannot be reasonably contained
at this time with the resources that the
foundation has therefore the focus has
shifted from containment to
neutralization which is ongoing via
project Beluga any and all non-critical
resources will be funneled into project
Beluga as neutralization of SCP ubu is a
top priority additional information on
neutralization efforts is restricted and
may only be accessed by members of
project Beluga but in the end it won't
be magic Beluga that defeats this
monstrous creature it'll be the staunch
efforts of one extremely dedicated
researcher on May 12th 2588 The Entity
known as SCP ubu manifested in Kangas
Greenland like something out of the most
nightmarish Kaiju movie never made soon
after there was no more death but the
world was filled with such chaos and
despair that Humanity longed for that
Eternal release from its enormous
stomping feet to its cloa to it it face
featureless save for a gaping grinning
devouring mouth The Entity was pure
malice with all the time in the world
ubu decimated the planet breaking the
spirit of mankind and raising every city
to the ground in the earlier days of
ubu's invasion when there was still dry
land and people still wanted to talk to
each other rather than joining floating
islands of Eternal chemically induced
Slumber they would commiserate about the
shared misery of the state of things oh
UVU my daughter hasn't spoken to me ever
since that monster shoved my whole body
down her throat someone would say
another would pipe up trying to one up
the first man in sort of a trauma
Olympics didn't you see me in the news
ubu carried me around for a week
snacking on me every now and then like I
was his own personal Turkey Leg it was
hell but honestly part of me felt a
little bummed out when he threw me away
yet another person would chime in like
veterans swapping War Stories over a
drink at the bar ubu made me eat a pair
of my pants whole thing zipper and all
then he decided he thought that was
funny made me eat pair after pair after
pair of them rinse and repeat by the
time he got bored I'd eaten probably
around 20 pairs and sort of got a taste
for them after that everyone on the
planet had good reason to despise
scpu but no one held more hate in his
heart for the pale Wicked creature than
Dr Lawrence mikal before the world was
turned upside down sometimes literally
Dr moud was a member of the mysterious
05 council at the SCP Foundation to be
specific he was
05-11 but that prestigious position at
the foundation couldn't protect him or
his loved ones from the wrath of ubu
when Dr moud was off duty ubu attacked
him and his wife first it impaled his
wife on a broom handle next it threw Dr
moud into an open pool of sewage in the
street then it bathed him in the filthy
water using his screaming wife as a
scrubbing brush all the while whistling
a horrible little bathtub song centuries
after that awful experience as Dr moud
watched most of his colleagues give up
and choose the closest thing to death in
this broken world he became even more
determined to do something about it on
January 14th 3030 Dr moud abandoned the
scps naith and his fellow 05 council
members in search of the scps Corn crate
an abandoned craft to the southeast it
wasn't an easy Journey rowing all the
way there in a Lifeboat never knowing
when the Great White Beast would emerge
from the water and choose him as its
next unfortunate play thing he could see
the scps corn cek still floating there
untouched but before he could row any
closer something collided with the
lifebo From Below snapping it in half Dr
macau's stomach dropped at the sight of
pale flesh but it was soon replaced with
relief when he saw that the thing that
had broken his lifeb was not in fact ubu
it was an injured narwhal behaving
erratically due to its wounds the
culprit was almost certainly ubu it
wasn't content to just torment humans
but instead must have been targeting any
life form that could feel pain and fear
in his own words Dr moud had put it at
least a mass extinction wouldn't have
made it that personal after the lifebo
broke apart moud swam to the conre
exhaustion and cold straining his
muscles it took him 2 hours to reach the
abandoned cargo barge and containment
site but eventually he managed to climb
up over the side and get on board there
was one very special thing about the
corn crate the thing that made it worth
crossing the ocean in a fragile little
Lifeboat to find every anomaly that made
the ganam list the list of anomalies
considered too dangerous to abandon even
in an apocalyptic scenario was contained
on the corn crake if there was anything
left that the foundation or anyone else
hadn't tried to use to defeat ubu it
would be on that ship after taking a
little while to recover Dr moud embarked
on an initial exploration of The Craft
all the staff were gone as he had
expected thankfully he still had his 05
ID card and it still worked like a charm
unlocking all of the automated security
systems on board a lot of what he found
was in Ruins but some things had
survived he found 10 hominid replicators
from SCP 2000 in perfect working order
there was a cage containing the remains
of SCP 2845 the deer though ubu had done
significant damage to it SCP 319 a
curious device was there contained in a
space locked vacuum chamber this one was
notable for its potential ability to
destroy the universe he found a couple
of safe class anomalies such as SCP yez
crowd control for the Practical Optimist
and SCP FNA the portable warehouse the
latter of the two was a portable door
frame to a pocket Dimension he also
stumbled upon SCP 001 Last Ride of the
day an old Prometheus labs prototype of
a time machine and possibly most
importantly he found SCP
076 the coffin was open but Abel didn't
attack Dr maoud he wasn't consumed with
murderous rage and blood lust the way he
always was before instead he was just
sitting on the edge of the ship silently
staring at the sea when he spotted moud
he gave him a small wave and did nothing
else the centuries of a world without
death a world without killing without
victory in battle battle had taken its
toll on him for possibly the first time
in his eternal life Abel was depressed 9
days after he first inspected the Corn
Creek mik began to formulate a plan he
loaded all of the hominid receptors into
SCP FNA using a thankfully still working
forklift next he was able to unseal the
sealed portion of SCP 001 Last Ride of
the day and get his hands on the details
of the anomaly it read SCP 001 is
capable of temporally relocating to its
relative position 15,000 years prior to
activation this temporal displacement is
Divergent Paradox Irrelevant in other
words a separate timeline is created as
a landing point for example if an
occupant from timeline X were to murder
their parents in utero in Timeline y the
Y iteration of the occupant would no
longer exist but the occupant themselves
being from X would be unharmed when in a
fully active State SCP 001 deploys a 5 m
High telescopic antenna that functions
as a coloo wave energy sink essentially
Colo waves could only be produced as a
byproduct of the universe suddenly being
exterminated and ZK class reality
failures produce the most Colo waves in
one of these scenarios SCP 001 would be
able to use these waves to go back in
time 15,000 years effectively resetting
reality to a point far before the
catastrophe happened this information
allowed him to put his plan together to
resurrect project Beluga step one plant
explosive charges around SCP 319 step
two hide anything potentially useful
against SCP ubu inside of SCP FNA step
three get into the cockpit with SCP FNA
and toe step four raise the Colo sink
and step five blow the whole thing up 3
days later it was time to put the plan
into motion Dr moud placed the charges
around SCP 319s vacuum chamber there was
enough in place to implode the walls of
the vacuum chamber he closed the
bulkhead and began deploying the Colo
sink 10% 25% 30% suddenly he could hear
a loud crashing sound the ship began to
tilt oh no he could hear the distant
sound of menacing Giggles the sync
reached 45 57 but as ubu grew closer he
quickly overrode the system to lower the
sink 45% 30% 25% 10% ubu grew closer and
closer and as it approached it began to
whistle the tune it once used when it
bathed moud and his wife in the sewer
ubu began to pound against the blast
door becoming increasingly frustrated as
it struggled to break through suddenly
another voice cut through the air an
unexpected one SCP 076 Abel called out
to maod encouraging him to carry on
while Abel held the Beast back as Abel
and yubu engaged in an epic battle maau
sudden remembered something there was an
Express deployment module for the K Co
syn with no time to waste he activated
it all at once he hit the Detonator and
then the year was
11,970 and the date was February 14th
13963 years later the SCP Foundation
discovered something beneath a mound of
Earth and snow near the northern border
of lapan Finland it was a shipping
container with a reinforced exterior the
interior of which could only be accessed
through a fortified bulkhead on one side
the words SCP 001 were written on the
side in black paint in spite of this the
object was given the designation as CP
848 a narrow winding tunnel through the
mound of Earth and snow was discovered
leading from the door to the outside
world the tunnel had significant wear
clearly having been used as a foot path
by someone but who well on April 12th
1993 the foundation got their answer SCP
8 48's bulkhead opened and a man stepped
out snapping his fingers and promptly
sealing the door behind him he was
designated pole 848 he was a 32-year-old
man of French Canadian descent answering
to the name of Dr Lawrence moud he made
a series of claims that the foundation
found dubious but noted it in the
official file for SCP 848 just the same
these included but were not limited to
SCP 848 is a time machine he held the
office of 05-11 in the 3030 from an
alternate timeline said timeline
experienced a modified Omega K class
endof death scenario that coincided with
the invasion of a Tiamat class anomaly
known as SCP ubu SCP ubu was an
extremely dangerous and sadistic entity
who was capable of among other things
neutralizing SCP 169 and SCP 682 his
timelines version of the foundation
launched project Beluga which resulted
in an impossible war with SCP ubu that
lasted 441 years Paul 848 deliberately
sabotaged SCP 319 to act as a power
source for SCP 8848 thus arriving in
Lapland in the year
11,970 BCE SCP ubu will arrive in
Greenland on May 12th
2588 Paul 848 was able to extend his
lifespan by sharing his Consciousness
between a Central Computer within SCP
848 and several thousand bodies created
by his personal hominid replicators said
Consciousness sharing was achieved
through a book classified in the future
as SCP yez he wishes to assist the
foundation in the termination of SCP ubu
and has laid out a plan for its
termination as outlined in document 8048
dzeta there were of course concerns
about the man's legitimacy but after
moud mentioned over 104 specific terms
and data points known only to members of
the 05 Council the foundation was forced
to take him at at least a little bit
seriously a motion was filed requesting
that poll 8048 be allowed to assist the
foundation with the termination of SCP
ubu as per document 848 Zeta 054 voted
yay 057 abstained and the rest of the
council voted nay the motion failed to
pass a follow-up motion was filed in
response requesting that poll 848 be
allowed to assist the foundation with
their own strategy to respond to SCP ubu
05-15 5-4 057 and 05-10 abstained from
voting the rest voted nay the motion
failed to pass on April 14th 1995 Dr
Isaiah Henderson and pole 848 sat down
for an interview when asked to State his
name Dr mcau also recited a mimetic
passphrase that when spoken by anyone
other than 05-11 of past or present
would cause them to burst into flames
the two men were at odds from the
beginning Dr Macau expressed dismay and
frustration that his proposed proposal
was rejected meanwhile Dr Henderson
countered with the insistence that
macau's proposed plan was rejected for
posing an unnecessary risk to the
civilian public they debated for a
moment before Dr Henderson announced the
foundation's next plan of action Dr moud
was to be terminated the foundation
would proceed with its plans without him
at that point Dr Henderson terminated
moud as ordered he didn't count on one
thing though moud was no longer an
ordinary man bound to one body he hopped
into the body of a guard then into the
body of 05- 4 to deliver a vital message
he had started this plan alone and was
ready to bring it to a close alone
project Beluga would continue with or
without the foundation's support Dr
Macau returned to the bulkhead climbing
back inside and sealing it behind him he
had hoped to have the foundation behind
him he had hoped they would be allies in
the fight against the greatest evil
mankind ever encountered but they
disappointed him he had waited thousands
of years only for the organization he
devoted his life to to try and kill him
well he wasn't going to go down without
a fight this was bigger than the
foundation bigger than anyone and no
living person was as equipped to handle
ubu as he was so he resumed project
Beluga as a on man operation he issued a
mission statement which read as follows
on May 12th 2588 The Entity known as a
CP ubu invaded and pillaged human
civilization for no other motivation
than cruelty and selfish gratification
shortly thereafter project Beluga was
founded as a joint effort between the
goblo cult Coalition and the SCP
Foundation for the purposes of ubu's
Destruction ubu is not merely a threat
to human safety he's an affront to every
positive and loving Concept in the human
consciousness rather than our lives he
seeks to destroy our quality of life to
State his own sick desires think about
it the taste of ice cream playing with
your dog the way you felt after after
your first kiss that is ubu's sworn
Enemy No fate is too cool for him no
hatred is strong enough when project
Beluga Charter was signed 592 go
officers and Foundation staff were
present at the ceremony our troops
numbered in the hundreds of thousands I
Dr Lin moud am the only surviving member
and always will be what I lack in
numbers is compensated thousandfold by
my weapons my mind my replicated bodies
and the ons of experience the following
record serves one purpose alone that
once justice has been brought to ubu
humans in The Shining and golden ubu
free future will understand that one
person can accomplish through the power
of hard science and ra motion entwined
in a perfect and indestructible braid
and while we are at it you are very
welcome over the next several hundred
years mow worked to secure ownership of
conaso Greenland through a project
Beluga civilian front he evacuated the
civilian population from the area then
spent a century constructing a super
weapon with 100 high yield nuclear
weapons heat amplification runes a
targeting Beacon for SCP dag and five
antimatter Gathering pods from SCP H&M
in place he was finally ready for ubu to
manifest again Ranger halter felt the
bark of the tree trunk slamming into his
back practically knocking all the air
out of his lungs as he tried desperately
to slow his frantic breathing the sound
of his own panting filled him with a
sudden horrifying thought if he could
hear his own ragged breaths then it
could hear them too he clamped a hand
over his mouth quenching his jaw shut so
tightly that he thought his teeth might
Splinter as he pushed them together his
free hand gripped the tranquilizer gun
shuttering as the snap of a twig rang
out somewhere behind him it had caught
up to him already he could bolt make a
quick dash for a cover behind another
tree but but it was close enough now
that it would see him and if it did it
would come rushing after him with a
speed that even a season park ranger
couldn't match as much as he tried to
force himself to stay still the
Petrified curiosity got the better of
him halter peaked out from behind the
tree and immediately wished he hadn't it
had all started out as what sounded like
an everyday occurrence high at top his
watchtower in the Glacier National Park
Ranger halter had been enjoying the view
of Montana's Rocky Mountains a cup of
coffee from his thermos in his hand then
the familiar squawk of His Radio had cut
short his appreciation of the Serene
scenery halter side tossing the
remaining contents of the cup over the
tower's railing wondering what kind of
day he was in for as he went to answer
the radio most of the time things in
Glacier Park were as peaceful as they
looked but the park ranger knew that
staying Vigilant could make all the
difference when it came to finding a
missing hiker in time or the difference
between DET Turing a group of campers
away from a family of bears and having a
hell of a mess to clean up he pushed
down on the button for the microphone
connected to the bulky radio that took
up practically an entire desk halter
thank God came the relieved voice from
the other side we've been trying to
reach everyone put them on alert we've
got trouble reports of a coyote gone
feral attacking folks I'm on it halter
replied grabbing his gear from the
cramped Watch Tower as he continued to
speak into the mic where did the report
come in from not far from your station
I'd say about a click from your position
stowing his tranquilizer gun Ranger
holder descended the ladder from his
Watchtower down to ground level as a
park ranger holder valued the
environment he worked in and as a fan of
the SCP Universe we know how much you
value intricate World building or in
some cases World destroying but either
way we couldn't be happier to introduce
you to the sponsor of today's video
World Anvil World Anvil is a
comprehensive set of worldbuilding tools
that not only help you craft and
organize your unique setting but also
present it in a captain activating
manner from wik likee articles and
interactive maps to a full-fledged RPG
campaign manager and novel writing
software World Anvil has everything a
World creator could dream of world Anvil
equips you with over 25 templates
prompting you to dive deeper into your
Creations enrich your content by
embedding Maps images sound effects and
even little secrets for that immersive
touch with their Innovative design you
can easily visualize your world through
Maps Chronicle its history with
timelines and fine-tune events with
intricate details your crafted world can
be beautifully showcased on a unique
homepage inviting others to dive into
your vision got a sudden idea while
working on another no problem World
Anvil lets you swiftly create new
articles or link existing ones ensuring
you never lose track of your inspiration
but my personal favorite feature is
their interactive maps Beyond just
creating and uploading your own designs
you can directly link your Creations
allowing for a dynamic and engaging
experience and if you're collaborating
invite your team to refine line write
and even let your fans chip in I'm
currently working on my own interactive
map of site 17 and maybe I'll even let
you see it when I'm done but don't wait
for me dive into World Anvil yourself
and elevate your world building game and
here's a treat use our Link in the
description to go to world Anvil
docomo 51% off any yearly subscription
explore create and share with World
Anvil the sun was already starting to
dip out of sight behind the trees pretty
soon it'd be Pitch Black save for the
beam of his flashlight he had to move
fast coyotes were only known to attack
humans on rare occasions usually they
kept away at least enough to make them a
minimal risk but waiting for him just
west of the Watchtower wasn't a coyote
at least not at first watching it from
behind the tree moments later Ranger
Halter's stomach turned at the sight of
the creature it walked by py like a
human but the shape was all wrong its
legs looked broken but that hadn't
stopped it it from catching up instead
of bending at the knee they were
z-shaped pointing back behind the
creature then twisting back again in the
opposite direction at the Joint they
looked more like the legs of a dog but
they were far too big the same could be
said of the arms bent out of shape at
multiple points like its legs were the
creature was a mess of misshapen limbs
the cartilage and its ears had seemingly
reformed into points and there were
claws protruding from its fingertips
practically bursting out from where
human's fingernails would be but beneath
it all and what alarmed Ranger halter
the most was its skin it had darkened in
patches layers of fur sprouting over
those areas but there were still parts
that remained clear where skin human
skin was still visible peeling away to
reveal the new fur coated layer
underneath it looked like a grotesque
accident like something ripped straight
out of an old horror movie the kind of
monster that a mad scientist would make
by half Hazard splicing DNA and playing
God hter checked the tranquilizer gun in
his trembling fingers still empty after
that most recent shot he reached for
another Dart slowly sliding it into the
loading mechanism and readying the
pistol it cocked and made a sound the
creature's malformed head turned
snapping directly towards the source of
the noise directly towards halter he
turned to Sprint away trying to expand
the distance between him and it if he
was too close the D wouldn't have enough
momentum when he pulled the trigger the
toe of his boot snagged on something
solid unmoving a root from the tree he'd
been hiding behind he felt himself
tumble Landing with a hard thud against
the forest floor his gun it had fallen
from his grasp he scrabbled around in
the dirt for it barely able to see where
the tranquilizer had landed in the dark
just as his fingertips brushed past
something metal halter felt the force of
something heavy strike his back again
this time though it wasn't a tree it was
the creature it snarled nashing its
canned Jaws that were protruding out of
its skull rows of sharp teeth that had
uprooted the old ones bearing themselves
into the park ranger's neck and not
letting go until he'd stopped moving for
good a few short hours later a convoy of
mysterious unmarked Vehicles arrived at
Glacier National Park the rest of the
park rangers who had reported the
strange activity were approached by
shadowy figures who refus to give their
names or offer up any form of
identification other than just referring
to themselves as experts in things like
this not long after none of the others
would remember Ranger halter or the
incident that had led to his untimely
death after administering amnestics it
didn't take the SCP Foundation search
party long to discover a lone coyote
sniffing around the remains of a park
ranger covered in blood the wild animal
was captured to be brought back for
testing before being re-released into
the wild meanwhile the foundation
scoured the rest of the area until they
came across the real culit standing in a
clearing a short distance from a foot
path through the forest was SCP
1579 of course the next challenge was
getting it packed up and transported to
biosite 66 without touching it to the
untrained I SCP 1579 looks to be fairly
unassuming even as far as anomalous
objects go it is simply an old wooden
sculpture the kind that can even be
occasionally found in various wooded
areas throughout the world its age is a
Apparent from even one cursory glance at
SCP 1579 the partial damage to its Cedar
surface speaking to the numerous years
it has existed for along with the bright
green moss that covers it although
curiously this Moss doesn't seem to dry
out and die in responses to changes in
humidity nor does it affect SCP 1579
structural Integrity as for where it
came from and who made it those are
still unknown as if the answer to what
holds SCP 1579 anomalous properties
whether or not the cedar it was carved
from or the Moss coating the sculpture
possesses some unknown Properties or if
SCP 1579 was somehow imbued with these
after being created initial testing by
the SCP foundation's researchers
determined SCP 1579 to have an
abnormally high resistance to the type
of damage wood and particularly cedar
wood is susceptible to for one it does
not seem to show any signs of rotting or
natural degradation for another it is
also resistant to heat at least to a
certain extent it doesn't burn the same
way other objects constructed from
Cedarwood however this sculpture is not
entirely indestructible pieces can be
easily chipped off of the main body of
SCP 1579 and these splintered fragments
continue to carry the same anomalous
effects as the rest of the sculpture
even when separate from it but of course
you want to know about the creature how
does is this supposedly harmless if a
little structurally abnormal Cedarwood
sculpture connects to whatever it was
that killed park ranger halter well it's
quite simple actually SCP 1579 killed
halter not directly you understand but
by proxy through its further anomalous
properties still confused well then how
about a demonstration let's take a look
of one of the foundation's preferred
test subjects an Expendable member of
d-class personnel probably spending
multiple life sentences working here at
the SCP Foundation rather than behind
the bars of a maximum security
institution now what would happen if you
place this delightful individual in the
same room as SCP
1579 well nothing initially that is
until the subject touches the cedar wood
surface of the sculpture either out of
curiosity or following the instructions
of a foundation researcher that's when
the real anomaly starts the wooden
sculpture will exhibit a slight but
observable movement shuttering slightly
as if moved by an unseen Force this will
precede the person who touched the
object feeling a burning sensation that
kind of irritating painful heat that
spreads underneath the surface of the
skin the burning will always begin at
the area of their body that made direct
contact with SCP
1579 and touching it again at any point
will trigger a reactivation of the
sculptures anomalous effects subjects
experiencing the effect effect of SCP
1579 have described the feeling as being
akin to a bad sunburn that rapidly
spreads Across the Skin from the point
of contact only to stop once it has
affected a person's entire body
following the subsidence of the burning
sensation subjects experiencing the side
effects of touching a SCP 1579 will
notice an immediate change to Their Skin
Within a window of 3 minutes their skin
becomes thin and paperlike in its
texture before starting to peel away
once the stage occurs the peeling skin
will reveal a new layer underneath hence
the colloquially used code name for this
anomaly different skin however the
so-called different skin isn't merely a
new layer of otherwise ordinary human
skin instead it will belong to another
species entirely a person coming into
contact with SCP 1579 will find
themselves rapidly developing new skin
that shares the physical traits as well
as matching DNA to that of a number of
animal species it should be noted that
these features will continue to rapidly
develop until the subject is entirely
transformed and is no longer considered
to qualify as a human being as for the
specific transformation that occurs
there are a number of known outcomes
that repeat in the following cycle let's
say our DCL class we'll call them
subject a touched as CP 1579 at the
start of the cycle they would after the
burning sensation stops and peeling
begins start to sprout dark feathers
across cross their torso arms and upper
legs likely with a great deal of pain as
the sharp Quill of these feathers start
to burst out from beneath the skin
beneath the knees subject a will see
their legs start to become yellow and
scaly as well as a change that causes
their toenails to Simply start to
painfully protrude outwards until they
form pointed blackened Talons subject
A's face will also start to grow
feathers however these grow outwards
away from the areas of the nose and
mouth flight FEA will also protrude from
the forearms multiplying in number until
their entire body is covered at which
point subject a on every level including
genetically more closely resembles a
corvis korax more commonly known as the
common raven than a human being anymore
take another test subject subject B and
get them to touch SCP 1579 right after
their different skin is covered in brown
fur that's approximately 4 in Long their
lips and skin underneath the fur will
darken and their nose will become
constantly moist claws will start to
grow from their fingertips although
these will be notably smaller than those
of a fully grown creature of the same
species an ursus arctos horribilis or a
grizzly bear then we get to the point in
the cycle where some unwitting hiker
encountered SCP 1579 in the forests of
Glacier National Park Montana when this
subject subject C touched the cedar
sculpture their skin began to grow
layered fir
as the cartilage of their ears is
separated from their tissue and replaced
by new reshaped cartilage much like
subject B who SCP 1579 turned into a
grizzly bear subject C also had darkened
skin a moistened nose and longer sharper
Nails it was at some point during this
transformation that an unassuming park
ranger stumbled upon subject C
frightened by what he saw this Ranger
was unable to identify that what he
interpreted as attacks by some kind of
half-human half animal hybrid were
actually desperate pleas for help as
subject C was transformed into a coyote
although it's hard to say which
physiological change triggered by SC SCP
1579 is the most alarming or unpleasant
to experience The Fourth Kind is in no
way any more pleasant than the preceding
three in the cycle subject D of this
particular series of tests will find the
new layer of skin that emerges under the
old to be hairless and of a green
coloration often with brown markings
unlike the previous instances their skin
will rapidly begin to dry out and seems
to be far more reactive to the humidity
of the surrounding environment it is
also far thinner than that of the skin
possessed by other Transformations that
SCP 1579 causes so thin in fact that the
eyeballs of subject D will be visible
through its eyelids which rapidly become
translucent similar to those of the
sudakis reila otherwise known as the
Pacific Tree Frog repeated activation of
SCP 157 99's anomalous properties will
trigger the next transformation in the
cycle whether the Cedarwood sculpture is
touched by a new subject or repeatedly
by the same person in the latter
instance where a subject is reexposed to
SCP 1579 the additional changes their
body undergos will be significantly more
painful their already newly replaced
outer layer of skin will fail to dry out
and will begin bleeding instead three or
four consecutive exposures to SCP 1579
will lead to excessive bodily trauma for
the subject usually causing them to die
from shock before the fourth
transformation is complete and as we're
sure you can imagine an amalgamation of
a human a raven a grizzly bear a coyote
and a tree frog is hardly a pleasant
sight this unfortunate fate was suffered
during one of the first incidents with
SCP 1579 that brought the foundation's
attention to it during an elementary
school field trip a teacher who was
explaining the history of totem poles in
Native American culture accidentally
touched SC SCP
1579 while experiencing the pain of her
transformation she fell against the
sculpture in a panic not realizing it
had been what caused her to change this
repeated triggering of the object's
anomalous effects led to her untimely
death an event that had to be wiped from
the minds of her students by the
foundation using the careful application
of Class B amnestics for now SC SCP 1579
is kept in a secure sterile environment
at a foundation storage Warehouse where
Personnel are not permitted to make any
contact with it so there's no need to
worry about accidentally running into
SCP 1579 in the wild although there are
always plenty of other things to worry
about while out on a hike through the
forest things that could be right behind
you now check out SCP 173 the sculpture
and SCP 1897 human domestication Society
for more